WELCOME EVERYONE I'M SORRY
ABOUT THE DELAYED START WE ARE
ANTICIPATING AND EXPERIENCING
IN- A LITTLE BIT OF TECHNICAL
DIFFICULTY WE'RE GONNA TRY TO
GET THROUGH THIS- JUST JUST TO
NOTE FOR SOME REASON- THOSE WHO
ARE REMOTE WHEN THEY SPEAK IT'S
VERY LOUD IN THE HEARING ROOM
SO IF YOU COULD. JUST BACK UP A
LITTLE BIT AND- NOT NOT USE
YOUR LOUDEST VOICE NOT USE YOUR
BLOOD AND I'VE ALWAYS- GOD I
HATE TELLING PEOPLE NOT TO
SPEAK LOUD BUT- IT'S REALLY
LOUD- SO GOOD GOOD. AND WELCOME
MY NAME IS WHAT IN A GONZALEZ
AND THE ASSEMBLY FOR THE
EIGHTY. DISTRICT THAT'S
PORTIONS OF SOUTH SAN DIEGO
NATIONAL CITY AND CHULA VISTA.
AT THIS IS THE FIRST INAUGURAL
MEETING OF THE SELECT COMMITTEE
ON LATINA IN EQUITIES. SO THIS
IS AN IMPORTANT- FIRST STEP FOR
US. I WANT TO FIRST THANK ALL
OF YOU FOR JOINING US TODAY-
FOR THIS INFORMATIONAL HEARING.
TODAY WE'RE GOING TO HEAR FROM
ECONOMIC AND HEALTH EXPERTS
ABOUT THE HARDSHIPS LATINAS IN
THE STATE CONTINUE TO FACE
BECAUSE OF KOBE NINETEEN
PANDEMIC. LATINA FRONTLINE
WORKERS WILL ALSO JOIN US AND
SHARE THEIR EXPERIENCES AND
CHALLENGES. THAT THEY HAVE
FACED DURING THE PANDEMIC.
BEFORE WE GET JUST A HOW. ITEM
DO TO THE KOBE NINE PAN AND-
WITH EXISTING PROTOCOLS THERE'S
LIMITED SPACE IN HER ROOM FOR
MEMBERS AND PUBLIC. MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC AND PRESS. I DON'T
SEE ANYONE IN THE HEARING ROOM
IT BUT IF YOU COME INTO THE
HEARING ROOM THERE MIGHT BE
SOMEBODY UPSTAIRS WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE YOU MAINTAIN- THE
REQUIREMENTS OF AT LEAST SIX
FEET APART AND YOU MUST WEAR A
MASK. WELCOME IT WILL TAKE
PLACE AFTER THE SECOND TWO
PANEL- DURING THE PANEL MEMBERS
MAY BE ASKING QUESTIONS
DIRECTLY TO THE PANELISTS BUT
DURING THE SECOND. AFTER THE
SECOND PANEL. YOU CAN'T PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT IF YOU CHOOSE.
PLEASE CALL OUR TOLL FREE LINE
AT. EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN SIX NINE
TWO EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN. THE
ACCESS CODE IS ONE THREE ONE
FIVE. FOUR TWO ZERO TWO. THIS
NUMBER CAN ALSO BE FOUND ON THE
ASSEMBLY'S WEBSITE UNDER
TODAY'S EVENT. I LIKE TO START
BY THANKING MY COLLEAGUES WHO
ARE HERE TODAY AND THOSE TUNING
IN AND TORTURE FACT PANELISTS
WHO ARE HERE- TO SPEAK
VIRTUALLY. WHAT WE KNOW IS THIS
BFORE WE EVEN ENTERED THE
PANDEMIC LATINOS AS A
DEMOGRAPHIC IN CALIFORNIA WHICH
IS ABOUT 20% OF THE POPULATION.
ALREADY WERE FACING SUBSTANTIAL
HARDSHIPS WE HAVE THE LARGEST
PAY GAP IN THE NATION FOR
LATINAS VERSUS ANY OTHER
DEMOGRAPHIC. IN FACT IT'S FORTY
TWO CENTS ON THE DOLLAR. FOR
WHAT EVERY WHITE MAN MAKES
WE'VE HAD HEALTH DISPARITIES.
AND WE'VE HAD- ISSUES THAT
AFFECT THE LIVES OF LATINOS WHO
ARE SO OFTEN GONE UNSEEN IN THE
STATE ACROSS THE UNITED STATES.
HOWEVER THIS PANDEMIC HAS ALSO
AFFECTED LEVINE IS IN A
DISPROPORTIONATE WAY. SO WE'RE
GONNA OUTLINED THAT TODAY SO
THAT MAYBE WE CAN COME OUT OF
THIS WITH SOME IDEAS AND
POSSIBLE. WAYS IN WHICH WE CAN
TACKLE- THESE DISPARITIES AS WE
MOVE FORWARD. THIS IS I WANT TO
THANK THE SPEAKER FOR ALLOWING
US TO PUT TOGETHER THE SELECT
COMMITTEE IT IS VERY UNIQUE-
AND THE REASON HE- ALLOWED US
TO DO SO IS BECAUSE HE DID
RECOGNIZE. THE DISPARITIES THAT
WE HAVE- NOT JUST IN THE LATINO
COMMUNITY BUT SPECIFICALLY TO
LETTING US. SO WITH THAT I
DON'T WANT TO- I CAN I CAN GIVE
YOU A BUNCH OF STATS BUT I'M
SURE WE'RE GOING TO HEAR A LOT
FROM OUR PANELISTS. AND I WANNA
START WITH OUR FIRST PANEL-
INTERVIEWS EACH PANELIST AND
YOU'LL HAVE SEVEN MINUTES UP
SEVEN MINUTES EACH TO SPEAK.
AND AFTER THE SPEAKERS HAVE
FINISHED THEIR PRESENTATIONS WE
CAN OPEN UP TO QUESTIONS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS I DO WANNA
NOW AND I'M REALLY EXCITED
ABOUT THIS. WE SET OUT TO FIND
EXPERTS AND- WORKERS WHO WERE
LUCKY NOT TO TALK ABOUT IT AND
YOU KNOW WHAT IT WASN'T HARD AT
ALL. THERE ARE PLENTY OF
QUALIFIED LEVINE EXPERTS WHO
CAN TALK ABOUT ISSUES- DEALING
DEALING WITH OUR COMMUNITY AND
SO I THINK THAT'S IMPORTANT. WE
WANT TO HIGHLIGHT THAT ALTHOUGH
WE ARE UNSEEN WE ARE HERE AN
ACCOMPLISHED AND ARE WORKING ON
THIS IN OUR OWN COMMUNITY. BUT
WE NEED OTHERS TO SEE US AS
WELL. SO WITH THAT FIRST UP DR
ELSA MACIAS IS A RESEARCH
ANALYST IN THE HOPE CONSULTANT.
BEFORE THE IF. I SORRY-
DOCUMENTS FOR I. SURE BE HAPPY
TO OPEN IT UP TO. MEMBERS ARE
THE COMMITTEE OF THEY'D LIKE TO
MAKE A VERY QUICK- OPENINGS. AT
LEAST DID YOU WANT MISTER S.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR I WANT TO
THANK YOU AND YOUR COMMITTEES
FOR THE HEARING ON SUCH AN- TOP.
IT'S DUE TIME WE ADDRESS
SYSTEMIC LETTING US FACE I
WOULD LIKE TO EXTEND MY
GRATITUDE ALSO TO SPEAK RENDON
FOR THE CREATION OF A SELECT
COMMITTEE AND I WOULD LIKE TO
THANK YOU OUR CHAIR LORENA
GONZALEZ FOR BEING THE FIERCE
ADVOCATE. OVER AND OVER AND
OVER AGAIN ON THIS ISSUE I WANT
TO THANK IN ADVANCE THE
PANELISTS FOR THEIR EXPERTISE
AT THEY'RE GOING TO SHARE WITH
US TODAY. IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA ONE OF FIVE
RESIDENTS IDENTIFY AS LATINA.
ACCORDING TO THE STUDY. LATINOS
ARE CRUCIAL OF THE FAT OF OUR
SOCIETY HOW OVER THEY NEED. THE
NEEDS OF OUR COMMUNITY YOU TO
BE. HI COMMITTEE SENDS A STRONG
MESSAGE TO ALL WE WILL NO
LONGER TOLERATE LEAVING LATINOS
TO STRUGGLE IN THE SHADOWS IT'S
TIME WE WORK TOGETHER TO
ADDRESS THE VARIOUS NEEDS OF
THE LATINO COMMUNITY. THERE'S A
LOT OF WORK TO BE DONE AND DR
ED SO MUCH MY CS ONE OF OUR
PANELISTS. HAS NOTED THAT
LATINOS MADE LITTLE TO NO
PROGRESS IN TERMS OF WAGE
EQUITY. LETTING US CONTINUE TO
MAKE FORTY TWO CENTS FOR EVERY
DOLLAR A WHITE MAN MAKES THIS
TREND HAS PERSISTED SINCE TWO
THOUSAND SEVEN ACCORDING TO NBC
NEWS. IN LIGHT OF THE CODE NOW.
PANDEMIC NOW IS EVEN MORE
CRUCIAL. ON EQUITY CANNOT
LATINO WHEN. BEHIND LIKE WAS
DONE IN THE GREAT RECESSION.
I'M LOOKING FORWARD TO MAKING
SURE THAT WE KEEP IN
CONSIDERATION THE LAYERS OF
INTERSECTION MALADY WHICH
AFFECTS WHAT THE MASS RACISM
SEXISM DOCUMENTATION STATUS.
INDIGENOUS STATUS SEXUAL
ORIENTATION GENDER
IDENTIFICATION AMONG OTHERS.
THE THESE ISSUES FACING THAT
ARE FACED BY LATINOS ARE MANY
HOWEVER THROUGH THE LEADERSHIP
OF AMAZING WOMEN SUCH AS ABOUT
OUR COMMITTEE MEMBERS. AND OUR
CHAIR AND OUR PANELISTS I AM
CERTAIN THAT WE CAN ACHIEVE A
NEW REALITY FOR LATINOS AND I
LOOK FORWARD TO WHAT WE CAN
ACHIEVE THROUGH THIS COMMITTEE.
THE LEGISLATION AND THROUGH OUR
OWN PERSISTENCE THANK YOU.
THANK YOUNG TECH AT IS. THERE
ANY OTHER YEAR YES MR CARLA
KALRA. THANK YOU SO MUCH MA'AM
SURE AND I JUST YOU KNOW TO
EVERYTHING THAT YOU AS WELL A
NUMBER OF AREAS AND GRATEFUL TO
THE SPEED. AS WELL AS HUGE
GONZALEZ- CONVENING THIS GUY
QUICKLY IMPORTANT- THE
SELECTION- YOU KNOW OVER THE
FEW AS MANY HAVE SEEN THE CALL.
PRICES HAS NOT COME ENOUGH.
IT'S A LONGS. AND EQUITIES OUR
AND I'VE SEEN IT PER HAND WITH
IT'S- WHETHER IT'S WITH
STRIKING MCDONNELL WORKERS MOST
WHOM ARE INTO WHETHER IS BE
WITH HOTEL WORKERS EIGHTY PER
OF THE LET OFF LOS OF THE
UNITED. OR BUT IN MY THE
CAPITAL'S VALLEY WILL BE HOW
THE THREE MO HEAVILY. ZIP CODES
IN THE BAY AREA TERMS OF AND
DEATHS CALLED IT- AND THOSE
WORKING. NEIGHBORHOODS AND
THOSE LIVE IN THOSE
NEIGHBORHOODS THAT ALLOW SO
MANY CALIFORNIANS TO BE ABLE
STAY AT HOME WITH FAMILY AND SO
I'M JUST GRATEFUL TO BE OF THIS
COMMITTEE AND I REALLY FORWARD
TO FROM THIS EICESTER'S. THE
SPEAKERS THINK YOU. IF THERE
ANY ELSE. MISTER JONES SAWYER.
ALL OF OUR. ANYWAY THE YEAH
MAYBE MAYBE. THREE OKAY- ALL
RIGHT ALL OF THEM YEAH. SB YEAH.
YEAH WE GAVE. WITHOUT. MR
CLINTON I SAID. I GUESS WHAT
I'M SAYING IS TO SHOULD BE A
LOT OF OPPORTUNITIES FOR A LOT
OF YOUNG LATINOS TO BE ABLE TO
COME INTO THE SYSTEM MANY ARE
NOT HEARD MANY OF THEM THAT ARE
GIVEN THE SAME RESPECT WE DO
WITH THEIR MALE COUNTERPARTS
THERE MAES WHO HAVE GIVEN THE
OPPORTUNITY TO COME INTO THIS
CAPITAL COME TO CORPORATE
AMERICA WITH THE SAME LEVEL OF
COLLEGE EDUCATION. MANY ARE
EVEN BETTER QUALIFIED AND
BECAUSE OF THAT OLD BOY NETWORK
DID NOT ALLOWED IN AND SO I'M
HERE NOT ONLY TO LISTEN TO THE
SPEAKERS ABOUT WHAT WE NEED TO
DO BUT I WANT US TO DO
SOMETHING AND NOT JUST TALK
TALK TALK WOULD ACTUALLY.
IMPLEMENT SOME THINGS BECAUSE I
DON'T WANT TO HEAR ANOTHER LIE
TO YOU TO SAY THAT THE DID NOT.
ABLE TO GET A JOB BECAUSE- SOME
CON. THE MILES GET BACK TO A
ROOM. AFTER WHETHER NOT WHAT
SHE'S GOING TO DO WHEN SHE GETS
PREGNANT. WHEN SHE GOT ISSUE
TOO EMOTIONAL. WHAT ABOUT HEAVY
LIFTING. WHAT ABOUT WORK HOURS.
THEY ARE GIVEN THE CHANCE
BECAUSE OUR OWN MAIL PREJUDICES
THAT THEY'RE NOT GIVEN THE
OPPORTUNITY USED A LOT OF THEIR
MALE COUNTERPARTS ARE GIVEN AND
SO WE NEED TO BREAK THAT GLASS
CEILING M. FOUR INTO MORE THAN
WE'VE EVER DONE BEFORE. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MISFIRED US.
THANK YOU AND I FIRST WANT TO
THANK THE CHAIRWOMAN AND THE
SPEAKER FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SERVE ON THIS COMMITTEE FOR
TRULY SHEDDING LIGHT ON THE
UNSEEN LATINAS IN CALIFORNIA
THIS IS A BIPARTISAN EFFORT AND
LATINAS ARE DIVERSE. AND THEY
ARE BUSINESS OWNERS THEY ARE
CARETAKERS THEIR MOTHERS THEIR
STUDENTS AND THERE ARE ISSUES
ARE JUST AS DIVERSE AS ANY AND
THIS IS A VERY FIRST IMPORTANT
STEP OF SHEDDING LIGHT ON THE
ISSUES AND THE PERSPECTIVES
UNWELCOMING LATINOS TO EVERY
TABLE AND I LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING HAND IN HAND WITH MY
COLLEAGUES ON THIS COMMITTEE TO
BRING LIGHT AND TO BRING
SOLUTIONS FOR LATINO WOMEN.
THANK YOU MISS RIVAS. I JUST
WANT TO THANK THE CHAIR FOR
CREATING THIS COMMITTEE-
ALLOWING US THIS OPPORTUNITY TO
HAVE THESE DISCUSSIONS ON
DIFFERENT ASPECTS ON WHY YOU
KNOW LIKE THE NICE CONTINUE TO
BE UNSEEN IN OUR STATE IN A
STATE WHERE THERE ARE IS A HIGH
PERCENTAGE OF LUCK THE MASS IN
CALIFORNIA- TODAY I'M
PARTICULARLY INTERESTED IN
HEARING FROM OUR PANELISTS ON.
OF YOU KNOW THE HEALTH IMPACTS
ON MY **** DURING THE COVERT
NINETEEN PANDEMIC YOU KNOW AS
MOTHERS CARE GIVERS AND
ESSENTIAL WORKERS I THINK
LATINOS HAVE REALLY- BARED THE
BRUNT OF THIS PANDEMIC THEY'RE
THE ONES THAT ARE STAYING HOME
WITH THE CHILDREN- POTENTIALLY
LOSING THEIR JOBS OR ALSO
CONTINUING TO HAVE TO WORK OUT
THERE TO PROVIDE FOR THEIR
FAMILIES- LOTS OF DIFFERENT
SITUATIONS AND I'M LOOKING
FORWARD TO DISCUSSING THAT
TODAY. THANK YOU. THANK YOU- MR
MCCARTY YEAH I THINK I WANNA
GET ON HERE FROM THEIR
PRESENTERS BUT JUST WANTED
KNOWLEDGE OUR CHAIR ASSEMBLY
WOMAN GONZALEZ FOR NOT JUST
CREATING THIS- SELECT COMMITTEE
BUT CHANTING THIS ISSUE BEFORE
THERE WAS THE HASHTAG ON SCENE
LATINOS AND IT TRULY IS
SHOCKING WHEN YOU SEE THE
RESULTS OF THE PANDEMIC THAT
ONE IN FIVE CALIFORNIANS ARE
LATINA BUT PEOPLE HAVE BEEN
HAMMERED. BY JOB LOSSES AND
ECONOMIC HARDSHIP BECAUSE THE
PANDEMIC WE'RE GOING TO SEE ARE
LATINOS- AND FOR WOMEN OF COLOR
BUT PUT ON THE CALIFORNIA
LATINOS BUT IT'S WOULD REMIND
US IT'S NOT JUST LEARNING ABOUT
THE PROBLEM BUT SOLUTIONS AND
REMEDIES WHETHER THEY'RE PAID
FAMILY LEAVE SICK DAYS MINIMUM
WAGE HEALTH CARE ALL THESE
POLICIES RELATE TO HOW WE CAN
IMPROVE THE QUALITY OF LIFE SO
LET'S LEARN TODAY AND FOCUSING
ON BRINGING ABOUT RESULTS. IN
THE MONTHS AHEAD THANK YOU.
THANK YOU I'M I KNOW THAT THERE
ARE SOME PEOPLE WHO ARE
VIRTUALLY AND- ARE. OUR MEMBERS
WHO ARE NOT IN THE CAPITAL-
BECAUSE WE CAN'T ALL FIT BUT I
KNOW CRISTINA GARCIA. CAN WE GO
TO CRISTINA I WANTED TO MAKE A
COMMENT THANK YOU. YES I WANT
TO THANK- THE CHAIR OF THE
COMMITTEE FOR HER LEADERSHIP
NOT JUST IN. IN GETTING THIS
COMMITTEE GOING BUT IN HER
TENURE IN THE LEGISLATURE SHE'S
BEEN A CHAMPION TO ENSURE THAT
LETS YOU KNOW VOICES ARE
ELEVATED- WE ARE OUT THERE. THE
FRONT LINES DOING THE WORK
FIGHTING FOR COMMUNITIES BUT
NOT ALWAYS YOU KNOW NOT ALWAYS
RESPECTED. AS A THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIRELESS LEADERSHIP
ADVOCATING THIS CLASS. PRESS
THE COME TOGETHER I WANT TO
ALSO THANK LEADERSHIP FOR
KNOWLEDGE IN THE NEED FOR THIS
AS WELL THE WOMAN'S COX'S HERE
TO BE SUPPORTIVE. IN THE EFFORT
TO THE CHAIRWOMAN S. ESTATE IT
IS- AS THEY TAKE THE LEADERSHIP
ROLE AND SO AS THE CHAIRWOMAN
OF THE WOMEN'S CAUCUS EXCITED
TO BE HERE TO SUPPORT OF.
MEASURE AND EXCITED TO HEAR
FROM OUR TALENTED AT THE MASS-
WHO HAVE A LOT OF INFORMATION
I'M SURE A LOT OF SOLUTIONS OF
HOW WE MOVE FORWARD AS WE'RE
LOOKING AT THE ECONOMIC
RECOVERY TO ENSURE THAT. THAT
THE NOTES ARE NOT AT THE END OF
THE LINE LIKE WE HAVE
TRADITIONALLY BEEN. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. AND I'M SO GLAD THAT
WORKED WE'VE- NEVER SHARE THE
DAYS. WE COULD AND HEAR YOU.
WITH THAT I THINK. WE WILL MOVE
ON TO OUR FIRST PANEL- AND I'M
SORRY AGAIN TO. DR MESSIAS WHO
WE LEFT WAITING AND HOPEFULLY
WE'LL BE ABLE TO BRING HER BACK
UP TO BEGAN. SHE'S A RESEARCH
ANALYST AND A CONSULTANT FOR
HOPE AND- SHE CAN GO AHEAD AND
BEGIN WHEN SHE IS READY. GOOD
MORNING ASSEMBLYWOMAN GONZALEZ
AND MEMBERS OF THE SELECT
COMMITTEE ON THAT THE NIGHT IN
EQUITIES. I'M ALSO THE CS I'M A
RESEARCH ANALYST REPRESENTING
HOPE. THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT FINDINGS
ON THE ECONOMIC STATUS OF THAT
THE LAST- BOTH BEFORE THE
PANDEMIC AND SETS- AS YOU HEARD.
I THINK THAT MAKE UP NEARLY 20%
OF THE STATE'S POPULATION
THAT'S A 40% INCREASE BETWEEN
TWO THOUSAND AND TWENTY
NINETEEN WITH MUCH MORE
EXPECTED OVER THE NEXT FEW.
DECADES ONE OUT OF EVERY FIVE
PEOPLE IN CALIFORNIA ISN'T THAT
ENOUGH AND IN SOME REGIONS OF
COURSE WHICH WAS MUCH HIGHER.
SO BEFORE THE PANDEMIC MANY OF
THE DISPARITIES AT THE NEST OCT
BASE HAVE BEEN FALLING TO
HISTORIC LOWS. BUT THEN IT HAD
MADE GREAT STRIDES SINCE THE
GREAT RECESSION IN BUSINESS
OWNERSHIP EDUCATIONAL OUTCOMES
HOMEOWNERSHIP AND PURCHASING
POWER THE VERY FACTORS THAT ADD
TO FINANCIAL STABILITY AND
BUILD WEALTH. BUT AS A GROUP
THEY REMAIN MUCH MORE
VULNERABLE TO ECONOMIC
DOWNTURNS AND IN FACT THE COPD
INDUCED RECESSION HAS WIPED OUT
MANY OF THOSE ECONOMIC GAINS.
IN BOTH THE CURRENT RECESSION
AND THE TWO THOUSAND EIGHT
RECESSION I THINK THAT'S A
STATE DISPROPORTIONATELY
GREATER FINANCIAL LOSSES. THEY
ALSO TOOK LONGER TO RECOVER
THAN OTHER DEMOGRAPHIC GROUPS
AFTER THE LAST RECESSION JUST
AS THEY ARE EXPECTED. TO DO FOR
THIS RECESSION. IN THE FIRST
SIX YEARS OF THE TWO THOUSAND
EIGHT RECESSION WHITE NON
HISPANIC HOUSEHOLDS LOTS OF
TOTAL OF 30% OF THEIR WEALTH.
WHILE HAT NEXT HOUSEHOLDS LOST
50% OF THEIR- BAND BETWEEN TWO
BY TWENTY SIXTEEN TO TWENTY
NINETEEN THE MEDIAN WEALTH LEFT
IN THE HOUSEHOLD ROSE FASTER
THAN THAT OF WHITE HOUSEHOLDS.
BUT IT'S STILL SIGNIFICANTLY
LESS THAN THAT OF WHITE
HOUSEHOLDS. THEY EXPECT THE
EXPECTATIONS THEN IS THAT LATIN
NEXT HOUSEHOLD WEALTH WILL
FOLLOW A SIMILAR PATTERN DURING
AND AFTER THIS RECESSION
UNFORTUNATELY. BUT EVEN SO BY
TWENTY NINETEEN THAT NEXT
PURCHASING POWER IN CALIFORNIA
ROSE TO FOUR HUNDRED FIFTY
THREE BILLION DOLLARS THAT'S UP
70% SINCE TWENTY TEN AND
REPRESENTS ABOUT A 20% SHARE OF
THE TOTAL BUYING POWER IN THE
STATE. THE GAP BETWEEN LATIN
ACCENT WHITE HOUSE WILL BECOME
NARROWED BETWEEN TWENTY FIFTEEN
AND TWENTY EIGHTEEN AS LET NEXT
HOUSEHOLD RECOVERED FROM THE
PREVIOUS RECESSION BUT THE
AVERAGE LET NEXT HOUSEHOLD
INCOME WAS STILL ONLY 68% OF
WHITE HOUSEHOLD INCOME IN
TWENTY EIGHTEEN. AND THEN
THERE'S THE WAGE GAP. THE
AVERAGE WHAT WORKING FULL TIME
YEAR ROUND IN CALIFORNIA EARNED
SEVENTY NINE CENTS FOR EVERY
DOLLAR EARNED BY A WHITE MAN IN
TWENTY NINETEEN. THAT YOU'VE
HEARD LIKE PEANUTS EARNED LESS
THAN FORTY TWO CENTS FOR EVERY
DOLLAR EARNED BY A WHITE MAN.
THAT'S A WIDER PAY GAP IN IN
TWENTY ELEVEN ONE NINETEEN S.
EARNED FORTY FIVE SECS. SO THAT
MEANS THAT BETWEEN TWO THOUSAND
SEVEN THE YEAR BEFORE THE
RECESSION AND LAST AT TWENTY
NINETEEN BUT THEN AS HAVE MADE
ABSOLUTELY NO PROGRESS IN FACT
THEY'VE LOST GROUND SINCE THE
HIGH OF TWENTY ELEVEN. HOWEVER
OVER THAT SAME PERIOD WHITE
WOMEN HAVE INCREASED BY THREE
STEPS. WHICH ISN'T GREAT BUT
CERTAINLY MUCH BETTER THAN NOT
BEING US AND TELLS US THAT
THERE SHOULD BE THAT THAT THERE
SHOULD HAVE BEEN PROGRESS FOR
LETTING US AS WELL. THE WAGE
GAP IS EVEN WORSE IN LOS
ANGELES AND THE SILICON VALLEY-
WHERE. THESE FIGURES ARE
EXACERBATED BY THE HIGH COST OF
LIVING IN EACH OF THOSE
REGIONS. BECAUSE OF THE WAGE
GAP THE AVERAGE THAT THE IT
WOULD HAVE TO WORK UNTIL THE
AGE OF ONE HUNDRED AND SIXTEEN.
TO EQUAL WHAT THE AVERAGE WHITE
MAN EARNS BY THE AGE OF SIXTY.
SO DURING THE LAST RECESSION
WHEN JOBS ARE HARD TO COME BY
MEDINA STARTED BUSINESSES. AND
THERE'S EARLY ANECDOTAL
EVIDENCE THAT THEY MAY DO SO
AGAIN TO GET THROUGH. THIS
RECESSION ESPECIALLY ONCE THE-
THE STATE OPENS UP. I THINK
THAT'S CREATED TWO POINT THREE
MILLION NEW FIRMS NATIONWIDE
REPRESENTING 18% OF ALL WOMEN
OWNED BUSINESSES. BETWEEN
TWENTY FOURTEEN AND TWENTY
NINETEEN. MOST LATINO OWNED
BUSINESSES ARE VERY SMALL MICRO
BUSINESSES THAT WITH LESS THAN
FIVE EMPLOYEES IN MANY MANY
WITH NO EMPLOYEES. GET THEY
STILL INCREASE THE NUMBER OF
THEIR EMPLOYEES BY 30% OR CLOSE
TO SEVEN HUNDRED THOUSAND
WORKERS NATIONWIDE. BUT DESPITE
IT BEING AS ENTHUSIASM FOR
STARTING BUSINESSES THEY ARE
LESS REVENUE THAN ALL WOMEN
OWNED BUSINESSES THEY'RE LESS
LIKELY TO HAVE EMPLOYEES LESS
LIKELY TO SCALE AND MORE LIKELY
TO OPERATE ON. RAZOR THIN
MARGINS. OUT BY MAY OF 202025%
OF EXISTING THAT NEXT
ENTERPRENEURS HAD LOST
SIGNIFICANT REVENUE DUE TO
PANDEMIC RELATED CLOSURES- BUT
WERE ALSO LESS LIKELY TO
BENEFIT FROM THE CARES ACT
RELIEF PROGRAMS. A WHILE IT
MADE SIGNIFICANT PROGRESS IN
EDUCATIONAL ATTAINMENT
PERSISTENT DISPARITIES IN
OUTCOMES RESULT IN AN
OPPORTUNITY GAP PREVENTING
STUDENTS FROM REACHING THEIR
EDUCATIONAL AND LIFE GOALS AND
IMPORTANTLY. THIS FOLLOWS THEM
INTO THEIR WAGE LEARNING WAGE
EARNING YEARS LET NEXT K.
THROUGH TWELVE STUDENTS HAVE-ALREADY FALLEN BEHIND A FULL
ACADEMIC YEAR LAST YEAR. AND
WITH- AND THIS TREND IS
CONTINUING THROUGH THE CURRENT
YEAR. THE TOP DRIVER OF WEALTH
CREATION IT IS EQUITY IN A
HOME. AFTER SEVERAL CONSECUTIVE
YEARS SIX POSSIBLY SEVEN YEARS
OF PURCHASING HOMES AT ABOVE
AVERAGE RATES THE LIGHT NEXT
HOMEOWNERSHIP RATE CALIFORNIA
ROSE 2404% IN TWENTY NINETEEN
COMPARED TO THE STATE AVERAGE
OF FIFTY FIVE. PERCENT BUT LIVE
NEXT HOMEOWNERS HAVE LESS
EQUITY IN THEIR HOMES THEY HAVE
LESS EQUITY IN THEIR BUSINESSES
AND THEY'RE LESS LIKELY TO OWN
RETIREMENT ACCOUNTS AND STOCKS
ADDED THAT THE WAGE GAP AND
LOWER LEVELS OF EDUCATION. AND
YOU HAVE LESS FINANCIAL
SECURITY AND GREATER
VULNERABILITY WHEN SESSIONS HIT.
BUT THE NOSE A JILL HERE LATER
MAKE UP A DISPROPORTIONATE
SHARE OF CONFIRMED NINETEEN OF
KOBE CASES IN CALIFORNIA. THE
FINANCIAL CONNECTION IS THAT
TWO THIRDS OF BANKRUPTCIES
RESULT FROM HIGH MEDICAL BILLS
OR TO TIME LOST FROM WORK. EVEN
FOR THOSE WITH HEALTH INSURANCE
THE HIGH DEDUCTIBLES AND COPAYS
PLUS JOB LOSSES IMPACT THEIR
ABILITY TO PAY FOR HEALTH CARE.
SO CONTRACTING CODE COULD BE
FINANCIALLY DEVASTATING AS WELL
AS DEADLY. BEFORE THE PANDEMIC
LEVINE AS HAD BEEN ENJOYING
SUCCESS ALONG VARIOUS METRICS
AND THE BROADER ECO SYSTEM OF
CALIFORNIA'S ECONOMY IS
INCREASINGLY TIED TO THEIR
ECONOMIC WELL BEING. SO WE
RECOMMEND INSTITUTING POLICIES
THAT MITIGATE THAT
DISPROPORTIONATE FINANCIAL
DAMAGES THAT DAMAGE THAT MEDINA
SUFFER WITH EVERY ECONOMIC
DOWNTURN. TO FACILITATE THEIR
ABILITY TO RECOVER IN THE SHORT
TERM AND HELP THEM TO REIMAGINE
OUR FUTURE IN THE LONGER TERM.
WE SHOULD SUPPORT THAT IN A
BUSINESS OWNERSHIP AND
HOMEOWNERSHIP ENSURE THEY ARE
PAID FAIRLY PROMOTE BETTER
HEALTH OUTCOMES THROUGH GREATER
ACCESS TO INSURANCE. AND URGE
THEM TO DIVERSIFY THEIR
INTEREST INVESTMENT PORTFOLIOS
BEYOND HOME OWNERSHIP. AND
ENSURE THAT THOSE WITH THE
GREATEST NEED AND THE LEAST
ACCESS TO RESOURCES HAVE
OPPORTUNITIES TO CLIMB OUT OF.
POVERTY THAT ULTIMATELY
BENEFITS THE ENTIRE ECONOMY OF
THE STATE. THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR YOUR INTEREST IN FOR
HOSTING THIS PANEL. THANK YOU
DOCUMENTS YES- WE'RE GOING TO
GO THROUGH THE ENTIRE PANEL AND
THEN OPEN UP QUESTIONS SO WILL
NOW MOVE ON TO DOCTOR MERRY
LOPEZ AN ACT NOT MAKES
PROFESSOR AT OCCIDENTAL
COLLEGE. AND UCLA U. C. L. A.
L. P. I. A POLICY EXPERT.
PLEASE GO AHEAD TO BEGIN WHEN
YOU'RE READY DR LOPEZ. ASSEMBLY
WHEN DOLLARS AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE ON ELECTION NIGHT IN
EQUITIES THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TODAY TO TALK
ABOUT. ON THE LABOR MARKET
CHALLENGES CONFRONTING MARTINEZ
G. CHIU PREVENT- NINETEEN- AND
OFFER STRATEGIES FOR ENSURING
THAT LET YOU KNOW SURPLUS FOR
FRONT OF THE JOBS. AND
EQUITABLE ECONOMIC RECOVERY- SO
IF YOU THE SLIDES HERE ARE
FOCUSED ON SYNERGISTIC THE KEY
LABOR MARKET OUTCOMES
UNEMPLOYMENT. LABOR FORCE
PARTICIPATION EMPLOYMENT CHIEF
POPULATION RATIO SO WE CAN SEE
THAT ON THE FIGURE HERE SHOWS
THE DISPROPORTIONATE IMPACT OF
THE PANDEMIC ON THE LABOR
MARKET MARKET OUTCOMES OF WHAT
SHE DOES. ALL THE WHILE THE
UNEMPLOYMENT RATE FOR LATINOS
HAS DECLINED SINCE REACHING ITS
PEAK AT NINETEEN POINT 8% IN
APRIL TWENTY TWENTY. IS YET TO
RETURN TO ITS PRE PANDEMIC
LEVEL RESULTING IN A WIDENING
GAP BETWEEN LATINOS AND WHITES-
OCCUPATIONAL SEGREGATION. AS
PARTLY TO RID OUR RESPONSE FOR
THIS IN JUST INTEREST SECTOR.
WE KNOW THAT BETWEEN FEB. AND
MAY OF TWENTY TWENTY THE
LEISURE AND HOSPITALITY
INDUSTRY- LOST ABOUT FORTY
THREE OR 42% OF THEIR JOBS
WHILE SERVICE INDUSTRIES LOST
ABOUT 27% OF THEIR JOBS. AND WE
CAN SEE HERE THAT WOMEN ARE-
CONCENTRATED IN THOSE-
PARTICULAR INDUSTRIES- AND
OCCUPATIONS ALSO LAST NEXT
WORKERS ALL ARE ALSO OVER
REPRESENTED IN FRONT LINE.
INDUSTRIES SUCH AS BUILDING OUR
CLEANING SERVICES OR WE SEE 40%
OF. BLACKS WORKERS REPRESENTED
THEIR RESEARCH ALSO HAS SHOWN
THAT ONE LOT NEXT WORKERS BUT
CUT BACK ON THE PAYROLL- THEY
WERE MORE LIKELY THAN WHITE
WORKERS G. REPORT BEING LAID
OFF AGAIN- WHEN LOCAL SEARCHES
AND INSPECTIONS RESULTED IN
FURTHER ECONOMIC SHUT DOWN. AND
NOT PRESENTS A BIG- CHALLENGE
FOR THEM IN TERMS OF GREATER.
JOB SECURITY. I IN TERMS OF HOW.
ARE EGGS ON A RATES HIGHER THAN
LAST AVERAGE AND WILL POINT
TIMES MORE. TO NOT BE COVERED
BY UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE
COMPARED TO OTHER RACIAL AND
ETHNIC GROUPS SO THIS
UNDERSCORES THE IMPORTANCE OF
EXPANDING ACCESS TO
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE AND
PROVIDING SUPPORT. FOR OUT
REACH OUT FOR ITS TARGET AT
WORKERS WHO ARE NOT AWARE OF
YOUR ELIGIBILITY OR REQUIRE
ASSISTANCE IN APPLYING FOR
BENEFITS. ON THE EMPLOYMENT TO
POPULATION RATIO IS ANOTHER WAY
TO MEASURE- THE CURRENT STATE
OF LABOR MARKET- IN THE SHORT
RUN TO FIGURE TO YOUR SHOWS
THAT LATINOS EXPERIENCED A
SHARP. JOB LOSS IN THE EARLY
MONTHS OF THE PANDEMIC- EVEN
THOUGH JOB CREATION HAS
INCREASED SINCE APRIL LATINOS
STILL- ARE THE FARTHEST FROM
RETURNING TO THE PRE PANDEMIC
LEVELS- AGAIN THE JOB LOSSES
POSE SIGNIFICANT ECONOMIC
CHALLENGES FOR LATINAS. IN
TWENTY EIGHTEEN FORTY ONE POINT
4% OF LATINO MOTHERS WERE THE
PRIMARY OR SOLE BREADWINNERS
FOR THEIR FAMILIES COMPARED TO
THIRTY SEVEN PERCENT. FOR WHITE
MOTHERS WE ALSO KNOW THAT
POVERTY RATES FOR LATINOS ARE
ALMOST DOUBLE THOSE OF WHITES
IN BOTH THE US AND CALIFORNIA.
ON IN ADDITION A LOT NEXT ON
LEE'S EXPERIENCE 265% INCREASE
IN WEALTH- AS OPTIMISTIC AS WAS
MENTIONED EARLIER ON THE LOT
NEXT WHITE GOT FELT VERY LITTLE
CHANGED VERY LITTLE- IN TWENTY
NINETEEN. WITH LIVE NEXT
HOUSEHOLDS STILL HAVINGMUCH
LOWER LEVELS OF WEALTH COMPARED
TO WHITE HOUSEHOLDS. A LOT NEXT
HOUSEHOLDS ALSO REPORT HAVING
AN AVERAGE ABOUT TWO THOUSAND
DOLLARS IN HIGHLY LIQUID ASSETS
WHICH ARE COMING FROM CHECKING
ACCOUNTS SAVINGS ACCOUNTS.
COMPARED TO EIGHT THOUSAND
DOLLARS FOR WHITE HOUSEHOLDS SO
THE COMBINATION OF JOB LOSS
INCOME LOSS HIGHER POVERTY
RATES AND PARTICULAR LOCK OF
WEALTH AND EMERGENCY SAVINGS
REALLY PUTS MANY OF THESE
LATINO BREADWINNERS- AND
ECONOMIC DESPAIR. AND IT'S NOT
JUST- IT'S NOT JUST AN WITH
ABOUT YOU KNOW- LET YOU
BREADWINNERS- BUT IT'S ALSO
SORT OF. A THE AND YOUR OF ALL
IN JUST. AND I KEEP. THAT ARE
ONE ARE FACING THESE CHAU- AN
EXCITING YEAR SHOWS. THE LABOR
FORCE FOR. RATE I'M FOR WOMEN
SO YOU SEEN THAT THE- LET'S USE
EXPERIENCE A DISPROPORTIONATE
DROP IN LABOR FORCE
PARTICIPATION RATES- SENSE OF
FEBRUARY TWENTY TWENTY OF ABOUT
6% OR THREE POINT EIGHT
PERCENTAGE POINTS. ON THE DROP
IN LABOR FORCE PARTICIPATION
ISN'T JUST COMING FROM LOST
JOBS IT'S COMING FROM WOMEN
ACTUALLY EXITING ON THE LABOR
MARKET THE LABOR FORCE. SO WE
CAN SEE HERE THAT- AND THIS
NEXT ROUND OF LUCK NEXT WORKERS
ARE LESS LIKELY TO HAVE PAID
SICK LEAVE IN. OTHER ALSO- LESS
LIKELY TO BE ABLE TO WORK FROM
HOME SO THE LACK OF JOB
FLEXIBILITY- AND BENEFITS MAKES
IT CHALLENGING FOR A LOT NEXT
PARENTS TO TAKE TIME OFF FROM
WORK TO CARE FOR THEIR
FAMILIES- AND THEIR CHILDREN
WHO MIGHT BE AT HOME BECAUSE OF
SCHOOL CLOSURES. SOTHIS
CREATES AN EVEN BIGGER
CHALLENGE FOR LARGER HOUSEHOLDS
OUR SINGER SINGLE PARENT
HOUSEHOLDS WHAT NEXT HOURS A
LARGER HOUSEHOLDS WITH CHILDREN
UNDER EIGHTEEN AND A LARGER
SHARE OF SINGLE MOTHER
HOUSEHOLDS COMPARED TO WHITE
HOUSEHOLDS. I'M AS A RESULT
SOME LATINOS MAY FACE THE TOUGH
DECISION OF CHOOSING BETWEEN
THEIR JOBS AND THEIR FAMILIES.
MOTHERS HAVE BEEN SHOWN TO BE
MORE VULNERABLE THAN FATHERS TO
THE PANDEMIC DETACHMENT FROM
THE LABOUR FORCE OUR RECENT
RESEARCH SHOWS THAT MOTHERS
WERE MORE LIKELY THAN FATHERS
TO TAKE A LEAVE- FROM WORK
DURING THE EARLY PART OF THE
PANDEMIC. AND SO WE'RE SEEING
HERE THAT WORKING LAST CHECKING
TIME OFF IN. PROMOTED LAST ALL
CONTRIBUTE TO LOWER EARNINGS
AND WILL INCREASE THE GENDER
EARNINGS GAP FARTHER FROM WHAT
WE SIXTEEN ALREADY IT ALSO HAS
IMPLICATIONS FOR THE OVERALL
ECONOMY IT'S BEEN ESTIMATED
THAT MOTHERS LEAVING THE LABOR
FORCE COULD COST SIXTY FOUR
POINT FIVE BILLION DOLLARS PER
YEAR- IN LOST WAGES AND
ECONOMIC. ACTIVITY ON THE
LONGER THAT WOMEN REMAIN OUT OF
THE LABOR FORCE IT BECOMES MORE
DIFFICULT OR REENTER TO
RESEARCH SHOWS THAT INDIVIDUALS
AND WHEN OUT OF THE LABOR FORCE
FOR SIX MONTHS OR MORE. ARE
LESS LIKELY TO BE CALLED BACK
FOR INTERVIEWS WE SEE THAT THIS
IS NOT JUST GONNA **** US.
THANKS AS WELL BUT YOU LOOK
YOU'RE DESPERATE FIGURE SEE
THAT AGAIN DO YOU DRAW IN LATE
FORCE WHICH IS. EVEN AMONG WITH
NO CHILL. ARE FOR A LOT TO LIKE
LARA THAN IT IS FOR THOSE THAT
ACTUALLY HAVE OUR CHILDREN. AND
INSURANCE ARE JUST SOME POLICY
RECOMMENDATIONS IT'S NOT CLEAR
TO DROP A SIGNIFICANT DROP IN
THE LABOR FORCE PARTICIPATION
RATE. AMONG LATINOS IS GOING TO
BE TEMPORARY OR WHETHER WE CALL
MORE PER MINUTE. THE LONGER
LATINOS CONTINUE TO REMAIN OF
THE LABOR FORCE THE GREATER THE
DANGER THAT THEY WILL
PERMANENTLY REMAIN OUT OF THE
LABOR FORCE WHICH CAN HAVE LONG
TERM IMPLICATIONS. FOR
HOUSEHOLD INCOME AND EARNINGS
SO POLICIES THAT PROVIDE
GREATER SUPPORT FOR AFFORDABLE
CHILDCARE POLICIES AND EVEN
CREATE MORE CHILD CARE CENTERS
BECAUSE WE KNOW. THAT RESEARCH
HAS SHOWN LOW INCOME AREAS OCT
FUTURE CHILD CARE CENTERS COULD
HELP LATINAS MAINTAIN. THEIR
ATTACHMENT TO THE LABOR FORCE
AS WE COME OUT OF THIS
PANDEMIC. IN ADDITION JOB
PROTECTION POLICY SHOULD BE
ENHANCED AND EXPANDED TO ALL
WORKERS UTILIZE PAID FAMILY
LEAVE REGARDLESS OF THE SIZE OF
EMPLOYER OR THE NUMBER OF HOURS
THEY WORK. ALSO EXTENDING THE
MINIMUM NUMBER SIX DAYS
PROVIDED BY EMPLOYERS FOR ALL
WORKERS REGARDLESS OF THE
EMPLOYER SIZE IMPORTANT. LABOR
MARKET DISCRIMINATION AS CAP
LATINOS AND LOCANE INFLEXIBLE
JOBS THAT OFFER FEW BENEFITS SO
EFFORTS SHOULD BE MADE TO
REDUCE OCCUPATIONAL SEGREGATION
FOR LATINOS. TRAINING
OPPORTUNITIES AND OTHER
INVESTMENTS IN HUMAN CAPITAL
MAY HELP LATINOS MOVING TO
BETTER PAYING JOBS WITH GREATER
OPPORTUNITIES FOR FLEXIBLE WORK
ARRANGEMENTS. ALSO THE LABOR
MARKET EXPERIENCES I'VE
DOCUMENTS AND LATINOS MAY ALSO
BE CONTRIBUTING TO SOME OF THE
TRENDS THAT WE'VE OBSERVED. SO
DURING THE FIRST THREE MONTHS
OF THE PANDEMIC IN CALIFORNIA
EMPLOYMENT FOR IMMIGRANT WOMEN
STYLE BY 20% COMPARED TO
THIRTEEN PERCENT. FOR NON
IMMIGRANT WOMEN AND 9% FOR NON
IMMIGRANT MAN. SO EXCLUDING
UNDOCUMENTED LATINOS FROM
FEDERAL AND STATE SUPPORT.
PROGRAMS LEAVES THEM AND THEIR
FAMILIES I MANY WHO ARE PART OF.
STATUS HOW. WHERE LEAST ONE OF
MEMBER OF THEIR FAMILY A U. S.
CITIZEN. AND I'M VERY LONG
POSITION RESEARCH HAS HUGE NOT.
A DOC WORKERS AND THEIR
FAMILIES IN ADDITIONAL ROUNDS
OF STIMULUS. SHARKS COULD
RESULT IN A FOURTEEN MILLION
DOLLAR INCREASE IN OVERALL
ECONOMIC OUTPUT. FINALLY I
THINK. I FEEL THE BEST THING WE
CAN DO FOR LATINOS IS- INCREASE
THEIR WEALTH. THE WEALTH
DIFFERENCE AND THE WEALTH
DISPARITY IS JUST SO STARK
COMPARED TO EVEN THE WAGE AND
INCOME DISPARITIES. SO THE
RACIAL AND ETHNIC GAPS IN
WEALTH NEED TO BE ADDRESSED
GREATER ACCESS TO WEALTH ALLOWS
HOUSEHOLDS TO BETTER WEATHER
ECONOMIC DOWNTURNS. AND WILL
ALLOW LATINOS THE RESOURCES TO
MAKE INVESTMENTS AND THEIR
HEALTH AND HUMAN CAPITAL AND
ONE WAY TO DO THIS AS WELL-
THAT DOCTOR MISSY IS ALREADY
MENTIONED. HOMEOWNERSHIP BUT
EVEN MORE IMPORTANT BUSINESS
OWNERSHIP BUSINESS OWNERSHIP
ENTREPRENEURSHIP COULD PROVIDE
LATINAS WITHIN OPPORTUNITY FOR
MORE FLEXIBLE WORK ARRANGEMENTS
AS WELL AS A WAY TO BUILD AND
ACCUMLATE WEALTH. SO PROGRAMS
THAT DRAW OR- PROGRAMS THAT
ADDRESS IN ANY QUALITIES AND
ACCESS TO FINANCIAL CAPITAL.
PROGRAMS THAT ALLOW AND HOPEFUL
WELL LET'S SEE THE BUSINESS
OWNERS REACH A BROADER MARKETS-
COULD ACTUALLY INCREASE NOT
ONLY BUSINESS STARTER SHOCKED
BUT HOW WELL THEY DO SO THAT
THEY CAN PROSPER AND USE. THAT
AS A WEALTH ACCUMULATION TOOL.
ON THANK YOU. THANK YOU DR
LOPEZ- WE THOUGHT IMPORTANT
OBVIOUS TO HEAR THE STATUS TO
HEAR FROM THE EXPERTS BUT ALSO
TO HEAR FROM THE INDIVIDUALS
WHO ARE ACTUALLY WORKING- ARE
THE WORKERS THE LATINO WORKERS
DURING THIS PANDEMIC- WE'RE
GONNA NOW HEAR FROM CYNTHIA
LOPEZ AS SHE IS A MEMBER OF
UNITE HERE LOCAL THIRTY- AND
SHE'S GOING TO SHARE HOW THE
PANDEMIC HAS AFFECTED HER
PERSONALLY SO SHE'S AVAILABLE
CYNTHIA. GOOD AFTERNOON PANEL
MY NAME IS CYNTHIA LOPEZ I AM A
MEMBER OF UNITE HERE LOCAL
THIRTY. I'M ALSO A REMOTE AND
THEN ON THE HILTON SAN DIEGO
BAYFRONT. I WOULD LIKE TO THANK
EVERYONE FOR THE OPPORTUNITY.
YOU'RE GIVING ME TO SHARE WITH
YOU SOME OF MY ECONOMIC
CHALLENGES. I'VE GONE. I'VE
GONE THROUGH BEFORE AND AFTER
COVERED NINETEEN. FOUR CORVETTE
I WAS WORKING FULL TIME MAKING
ABOUT A HUNDRED FIFTY FOUR
DOLLARS A DAY. THAT'S ABOUT
THREE THOUSAND DOLLARS PER
MONTH MY HAVE MY HUSBAND HAS
JUST STARTED WORKING AND EVEN
THOUGH BOTH OF US WERE WORKING
WE WERE STILL LIVING PAYCHECK
BY PAYCHECK. I THOUGHT WE WERE
ABLE TO PAY OFF SOME OF FOR
CREDIT CARD DEBT THEN COVERED
NINETEEN CAME ALONG. BRINGING
ECONOMIC DISASTER TO OUR FAMILY
NOW INSTEAD OF BRINGING THREE
THOUSAND DOLLARS PER MONTH I
HAVE TO RELY ON MY EIGHTEEN
HUNDRED DOLLAR UNEMPLOYMENT
CHECK. SOMETIMES WE HAVE TO
CHOOSE BETWEEN PAYING RENT AND
BILLS ARE FITTING OR FAMILY I
ALSO HAD TO GO. TO GO BACK TO
RELY ON MY CREDIT CARDS IN
ORDER TO MAKE ENDS MEET.
CORBETT NINETEEN HAS ALSO TAKEN
MY PEACE OF MIND BY LOSING MY
HEALTH INSURANCE. I HAVE THREE
I HAVE THREE KIDS ONE OF THEM
SUFFERS FROM AUTISM AND MENTAL
DISORDERS I AM WORRIED THAT HE
AND THAT ENDS UP HAVING A
CRISIS AND WE DON'T HAVE HEALTH
INSURANCE. I SIMPLY CANNOT
AFFORD PAYING FOR MY HEALTH
INSURANCE PREMIUMS MY SON HAS.
LOS ALL HIS THERAPIES BECAUSE
I'M UNABLE TO PAY FOR HIS
DOCTOR VISITS I HAVE ALSO HAVE
TO STAY HOME. BECOMING MY KIDS
TEACHERS BECAUSE I WILL BE FINE
IT WOULD BE FINANCIALLY
IMPOSSIBLE TO PAY SOME. SOMEONE
TO TAKE CARE OF AND TEACH MY
KIDS. MY ECONOMIC LIFE HAS BEEN
A DISASTER. SINCE CORBETT
NINETEEN. CAME AND ME AND MY
HUSBAND WERE FOR LOW FROM OUR
JOBS. THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY AGAIN FURTHER
LISTENING TO MY STORY. THANK
YOU- CENTER FOR SHARING WITH US
A STORY THAT UNFORTUNATELY A
LOT OF US HAVE HEARD OVER AND
OVER AGAIN DURING ON THIS
PANDEMIC. WE ARE GOING TO AND
FINISH UP THIS PANEL- AND THEN
WE'RE GONNA GO TO MEMBERS
QUESTIONS OF THESE PANELISTS-
STARTING AT WE ARE FINISHING UP
WITH THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED FARM WORKERS TODAY
SEVERAL METAL. IF SHE'S
AVAILABLE WILL GO TO TESSA.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GONZALEZ AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE- GOOD AFTERNOON-
CALIFORNIA FARMWORKERS HAVE
SUFFERED FROM A PERFECT STORM
OF DAILY CARE OF LAST YEAR. THE
GOVERNMENT NINETY MONDAY MAKE
EXTREME HEAT OKAY OKAY MARC
FROM WILDFIRES WE NEED TO
REMEMBER THAT APPROXIMATELY 45%
OF FARM WORKERS ARE WOMEN. AND
ALMOST A 100% OF THE WITH. YES
FARMWORKERS REYES- BALDOMERO
FOR HER. TO COMPACT CONTRACT
THE CURRENT VIRUS BECAUSE THEY
ARE. MONTHLY COMMUTE INTO THE
END OF. OR CRY FOR IN A SENATOR
CONDITIONS. AND HE'S LIKE YOU
DO HAVE INSURANCE. AT LAST HAVE
GET NOTHING BACK AND DON'T GET
ANY FEDERAL BENEFITS THAT HELP
OTHER AMERICANS WORKERS SURVIVE
BECAUSE OF THEIR IMMIGRATION
STATUS. A BIG PERCENTAGE OF
THE- WORKERS. ARE ARE
UNFORTUNATELY AND DOCUMENTED I
DO YOU HAVE DONE TO KEEP
CONSTANT CONTACT WITH
APPROXIMATELY FIFTY THOUSAND
FARMWORKERS. ARE MOST OF THEM
NOT UNDER UNION CONTRACT I
THINK WE DO IT THROUGH FACEBOOK
AND OTHER PLATFORMS IN SPANISH
EXCLUSIVELY FOR EVERY CULTURE
WORKERS. CONDUCTING SURVEYS AND
RECEIVING A STREAM OF COMMENTS
AND REPORTS OF THEIR
EXPERIENCES BECAUSE- I SHOULD
SURVEYS SHOW TOO MANY I KNOW
UNION EMPLOYERS HAVE NOT TAKING.%
PROPER PRECAUTIONS TO PROTECT
WORKERS FROM BY THE VIRUS. IN
PROVIDE P. P. S. B. B. E. R.
UNFORTUNATELY THE MAJORITY OF
OUR THE CONTACTS THAT WE HAVE A
OR THE BAD PEOPLE THAT WE TRIED
TO RISE. FOR SOME REASON ARE
ARE NOT I'M. OF I'VE BEEN.
WOMEN DAMAGE OF THEM ARE- I
THINK YOU'RE GOING TO NOTHING
TO DO CAN HELP CALIFORNIA NEW.
TO RECALL TWO WEEKS TAKES THE
FOR ADEQUATE WORKER INTO FOR
FARMWORKERS IF WE THINK ABOUT
IT FOR MORE AND CONSIDER CENTRO
I DON'T FOR A DO NOT ANYBODY
ANYTHING ANYTHING. I KNOW AT
SICKLY THEY THEIR WRAPPING UP A
WHERE THEY HAVE TO GO TO WORK
NO MATTER. OUR TOGETHER WITH
THE U. W. YOU HAVE TO FROM WE
YEAH THEY JUST. HI OF THOUSANDS
OF MEN OCTOBER FROM. AND NINE
FIVE EQUIVALENT FIRST
RESTAURANT MASKS PROTECT THEM
FROM THE WILDFIRES- GOVERNOR
NEEDS AMEND OUR ON MY THAT
PHASE ONE B. CARE ONE WHICH
INCLUDES FARMWORKERS. YOUR CASE
IS FOR VACCINES WILL BE BASED
ON AGE WHICH LEAVES MANY
UNANSWERED QUESTIONS OR
FARMWORKERS. NEW DATA WAS JUST
READ THAT REVEALED GREAT STUDY
FROM USE AS THESAN FRANCISCO.
HE DIDN'T ANSWER URGING NEED TO
CONTINUE PRIORITIZING
FARMWORKERS. BAY ON- BASED ON
DEATH CERTIFICATES FROM THE
STATE DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH THIS SURVEY ESTIMATED
ADDITIONAL MORTALITY AMONG.
EIGHTEEN TO SIXTY FIVE YEAR
OLD- CALIFORNIANS BASED ON
OCCUPATION WITH OTHER BREAKOUTS
COPPER. RACE AND ETHNICITY
RIGHT TO THE STUDY WORKING AGE
ADULTS EXPERIENCED A 22%
INCREASE IN MORTALITY COMPARED
TO HISTORICAL PERIODS. DURING
THE PANDEMIC HOWEVER. THANK YOU
EXCESS MORTALITY WAS HIGHEST IN
FOOD AND AGRICULTURAL WORKERS
39% INCREASE IN ONE LATINO
CALIFORNIANS IT MAKES 36%
INCREASE IN MORTALITY. THERE
WAS A 59% INCREASE AMONG
LATINOS. IN AB BUT YOU NEVER GO
TO WORKERS. I'M I- ECKSTINE IT
IS KEY ARE TO CONTINUE HAVING I
SAVE UP. WHICH TO PLY ARE FROM
THESE FROM WORKERS- I'M FIRST
AND FOR TO ME I. ARTICLE SAID
NINE. YOUR RECALL WORKER UNDER
ONE B. SO FAR THAT WE KNOW OF
ONLY RIVERSIDE DOING SO. I OF
ALL NIGHT THIS OF WOULD BE AS
HONOR TO FOLLOW SEARCH I IS.
ENACTED A BRIEF US ONLY TO
THROW OF THE YEAR FROM. HOWEVER
MY GREATEST WERE IN THE U.
STATES. I WAS BORN IN MAY. AND
I'M EQUALLY PROUD OF MY MEXICAN
SEPTIC AND HERITAGE US
CITIZENSHIP. IT IS NOT LOST ON
ME THAT I'M THE FIRST LIKE
TEANECK EMIGRATE TO SERVICE. OF
A NATIONAL UNION IN THE UNITED
STATES- WOMEN FARMWORKERS FACE
BURDEN MEN DO NOT. EAT IT IN
ADDITION TO DOING HARD WORK IN
VERY SKILLED WORK. WOMEN
WORKERS ARE ALSO WIVES AND
MOTHERS. THEY COME HOME FROM
WORK TO FEEDING THEIR FAMILIES
AND TAKING CARE OF THEIR KIDS.
THEY FACE SPECIAL CHALLENGES
AND INIQUITIES. ARE IN THE AGE
OF COLLEGE. FARMWORKERS CAN
SHELTER IN PLACE. OR WORK FROM
HOME. FEDERAL STATE AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS CLASSIFIED
ESSENTIAL WORKERS THEY MUST DO
THEIR WORK TO FEED AMERICA.
LACK OF TRANSPORTATION AND I AM
FROM THE FIELD IS THAT. A
BIGGER PROBLEM. FIGHTING RIGHT
IT'S NOW HARDER OUT OF THE
AFTER FOR COMPANIES. IN EVEN PP
IT'S SORT OF THESE THINGS
RECESSING ARE NOT OBSERVED.
WOMEN HAVE CHILDREN THEY COME
HOME FROM WORK TO MAKE SURE
THAT THE CHILDREN OF OUR FAITH
AND THEY HAVE. A THEY DO
WHATEVER THEY CAN TO ENSURE
THAT THE KIDS ARE- DETERRED IS
COOL WORK UNFORTUNATELY EVEN
MANY OF THEM DON'T HAVE ACCESS
ACCESS TO THE TECHNOLOGY TO
PARTICIPATE. I DIDN'T. IN
HOUSTON EDUCATION- IRAQ OF
CHILD IS THE NEED TO PROTECT
BIGGER DILEMMA FONG IF THE
ELECTION BECAUSE THEY ARE
FORCED TO LEAVE KIDS ALONE
WHERE THEY WORK IN NEIGHBORS
REPORT THEM TO THEIR FIRST
PAYMENT DEAL WITH INSURANCE
DISTANCE LEARNING FOR THE
CHILDREN WHAT THEY MUST BE AT
WORK AND THEY CANNOT BE IN TWO
PLACES AT ONCE SO WOMEN RELIEF
AT FACING MANY CHALLENGES. ARE
A GREAT CHALLENGES THAT WE'RE
FACING- A DIFFICULT TRADING
HISTORY. ALL OF THE THIS IS A
THE BUYER JUST. AFFECTING A
RECORD OR WORKERS. IT'S PAST
THE SPECIALLY WOMEN. AND AT
GOVERNMENTAL LEVELS MUST DO ALL
THEY CAN TO MAKE IT EASIER FOR
THESE. R. E. BEGINS WITH
GETTING FARMWORKERS VACCINATED
AS QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH CONSISTENT WITH.
THANK YOU. I AM WOW WE'RE GONNA
OPEN IT UP NOW TO QUESTIONS FOR
THESE PANELIST IF ANY OF THE
MEMBERS EITHER REMOTELY OR HERE
WANT TO ASK A QUESTION. WE
START WITH WENDY. CARILLO
SORRY. VERY CASUAL DURING CODE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
MUCH APPRECIATED I'M AND I'M SO
EXCITED TO BE PART OF THE
SELECT COMMITTEE AND TO BE ABLE
TO ADDRESS SOME OF THESE
ISSUES- THAT FOR MANY OF US WE
HAVE LIVED FIRST. MY QUESTION
IS FOR MISS LOPEZ- WHO IS A
PROFESSOR AT OCCIDENTAL COLLEGE
WHICH IS AN ASSEMBLY DISTRICT
FIFTY ONE SO I'M I'M EXCITED TO
TALK TO YOU AND I ACTUALLY NEXT
TUESDAY- I'M THE CHAIR BUDGET
SUB FLOOR WE WILL BE HAVING AN
OVERSIGHT HEARING ON SMALL
BUSINESSES AS WELL AS KELLY CAL
E. I. T. C. ROLLOUT. AND I'M
CURIOUS BASED ON KOVITZ SMALL
BUSINESS RECOVERY PLANS AND OF
THE GOLDEN STATE STIMULUS IF
THERE IS A POSSIBILITY THAT WE
CAN ACTUALLY TRACK OR HOW CAN
WE BETTER TRACK OF THOSE
RECOVERY EFFORTS FOR SMALL
BUSINESSES GOING TO. LET THE
MATH SINCE OUR LETTING US ASK
STATED ARE THE FASTEST GROWING
SMALL BUSINESS DEMOGRAPHIC NOT
ONLY IN CALIFORNIA BUT ACROSS
THE NATION I FIND IT IS ALSO
OUR RESPONSIBILITY AND OUR
CHARGE TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
FUNDS THAT WE HAVE ALLOCATED
FOR SMALL BUSINESS COVERT
RELIEF ARE ACTUALLY GOING. TO
ONE OF THE LARGEST POPULATIONS
IN THE STATE WITH SMALL
BUSINESSES WOULD LOVE YOUR
THOUGHTS ON THAT. I'M YEAH I
THINK PART OF THE PROBLEM WITH
WITH SORT OF LOOKING AT. LATINO
ENTREPRENEURS IS ALSO DATA
COLLECTION AND- AND SO YOU KNOW
A LOT OF THE LARGE DATA SETS
ARE PICKING UP. SORT OF
INFORMATION ABOUT SORT OF-
LARGER FIRMS- BUT THIS SORT OF
YOU KNOW STOREFRONTS AND A LOT
OF THE RESEARCH THAT I'VE DONE
HAS BEEN ON- LOOKING AT LATINO
STOREFRONTS- IS SOMETHING THAT
YOU WOULD NEED TO DO IN TERMS
OF LIKE A SURVEY AND REALLY
SORT OF TRACKING- THESE
BUSINESS OWNERS AND I THINK
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT. WE DON'T
NORMALLY DO AND DOCTOR NEEDS TO
BE MORE FINDING IN TERMS OF
LONGITUDINAL SURVEYS THAT
TRACKED THESE BUSINES OWNERS
OVER TIME PARTICULARLY SMALLER
BUSINESSES- IN TERMS OF SEEING
THEIR PROGRESS- I THINK YOU'RE
RIGHT AND IN TERMS OF MAKING
SURE THAT THEY HAVE. ACCESS TO
THE FUNDS- AND MAKING SURE THAT
IT IS ADDRESSING KIND OF SOME
OF THEIR NEEDS ONE OF THE
THINGS I ALSO THAT I WOULD SA
IS IT WHEN IT COMES TO
ENTREPRENEURSHIP. IS IT'S
REALLY ABOUT SORT OF ACCESS TO
MARKETS ZERO AND SO YOU KNOW IF
WE LOOK AT SORT OF THE
TECHNOLOGICAL DIVIDE THAT WE'VE
ALSO SEEN HERE- MANY SMALL
BUSINESS OWNERS DON'T HAVE
ACCESS TO THE SAME TECHNOLOGY
AS LARGER BUSINESSES. OR THE
SAME ACCESS TO YOU KNOW USING
TECHNOLOGY AS A WAY TO
ADVERTISE- BUT SMALL TOOLS WE
SEE LENA LET LET YOU KNOW FOR
EXAMPLE ARE ARE MORE LIKELY TO
ON THE PHONE AND USE THAT PHONE
FOR THEIR BUSINESS PURPOSES AND
SO. THINKING ABOUT ALSO NOT
JUST SORT OF PROVIDING START UP
FUNDS AND CAPITAL FINANCIAL
CAPITAL TO THESE BUSINESSES BUT
REALLY HOPING THAT I THINK
THINK THROUGH. THEIR BUSINESS
STRATEGIES HOW CAN THEY REACH A
WIDER MARKET- HOW CAN THEY USE
TECHNOLOGY IN THE INTERNET TO
REACH OUT WIDER MARKET WE'VE
SEEN A LOT OF BUSINESSES BE
SUCCESSFUL NOT AREA- BUT- BUT
THOSE THAT LACK THE TECHNOLOGY
OR THE KNOW HOW ARE ABLE TO
SORT OF REAP THOSE BENEFITS.
SO- I THINK THESE ARE THINGS
YOU KNOW ARE REALLY IMPORTANT
BUT I THINK TRACKING THESE
THESE BUSINESS ARE. AND SO THAT
IS OFTEN LACKING. AND SO WE
REALLY DON'T KNOW FOR EXAMPLE%
YOU KNOW HOW SUCCESSFUL ARE
SOME OF THESE INTERVENTION
PROGRAMS- OR IF THEY'RE EVEN
TARGETING THE RIGHT THINGS ON
IN TERMS OF. OF
ENTREPRENEURSHIP. BUT IT'S
DEFINITELY AN OPPORTUNITY FOR
THEM TO COME OUT- ON THE
STRONGER AND HERE IN TERMS OF
YOU KNOW IT'S A IT'S A WAY TO
BUILD WEALTH. IT'S A WAY TO
HAVE YOU KNOW JOB SECURITY IT'S
A WAY TO HAVE JOB FLEXIBILITY
SO. I THINK WE REALLY NEED TO
MAKE SURE WE NOW WHETHER THOSE
INTERVENTION EFFORTS ARE
WORKING AND HOW MUCH MORE WE
NEED TO DO. THANK YOU I REALLY
APPRECIATE THAT AND THAT'S AS A
FOLLOW UP- PROFESSOR LOPEZ- IN
LOS ANGELES COUNTY OR TE CITY
OF LOS ANGELES MEDIA SALINAS IS
THE FIRST LET THE NOT TO CHAIR.
THE ALLEY CHAMBER WHICH IT IS
AN EXCITING OPPORTUNITY I THINK
FOR WOMEN IN BUSINESS- AND IN
MY CONVERSATIONS THAT I'VE
SHARED WITH HER THERE'S BEEN A
DISTINCTION IN TERMS OF. HOW DO
YOU SUPPORT- LATINOS IN SMALL
BUSINESSES THAT ARE. AT THE
FOREFRONT OF THE CONVERSATION
VERSUS THE UNDERGROUND ECONOMY
AS WELL. AND SO HOW DO WE
COMPATIBLE E. OUT CREATE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR MICROLOANS
HOW DO WE ENSURE THAT BANKS ARE
BEING ACCESS BY. COMMUNITY
MEMBERS THAT. PERHAPS MAY NOT
FEEL SO COMFORTABLE IN GOING
INSIDE A BANK- ESPECIALLY RIGHT
NOW DURING COLD IT HOW DO WE
ENSURE TAT OUR MOST VULNERABLE
SMALL BUSINESSES LIKE FOR
EXAMPLE ANYTHING LOS ANGELES WE
HAVE. LET THE ANA OWN SMALL
LITTLE BE INDEED THAT'S LIKE A
LITTLE BALL DAY GOT TYPE STYLE-
STOREFRONT THAT'S BEEN HEAVILY
IMPACTED. BY COVE IT IT'S BEEN
IMPACTED BY A LOCAL COUNTY.
HEALTH INSPECTIONS AS WELL AS
CHANGING- CHANGING DIRECTIONS
IN TERMS OF WHAT IS POSSIBLE
WHAT IS NOT POSSIBLE DURING
COLD IT. AND SO I APPRECIATE
THIS CONVERSATION BECAUSE WHEN
WE THINK ABOUT. LATINA
ENTREPRENEURSHIP THERE ARE
VARIOUS DIFFERENT LEVELS IN
WHICH WE CAN THINK ABOUT
BUSINESS- AND ULTIMATELY HOW DO
WE ENSURE THAT TO YOUR POINT
THOSE WITH. A LACK OF ACCESS TO
TECHNOLOGY OR KNOWLEDGE OF HOW
TO FIND INFORMATION HOW THE
INFORMATION BECAUSE WE CAN
CREATE PROGRAMS ACROSS THE
STATE. THAT ULTIMATELY DO NOT
HELP. THE INTENDED. APAP OF
WOMEN ARE SMALL BUSINESS OWNERS
THAT ACTUALLY NEED THE MOST
HELP SO IT CREATES IN MY
OPINION LIKE A VERY TOP DOWN.
WAY IN WHICH WE DO GOVERNMENT
THAT AT THE END OF THE DAY
DOESN'T HELP COMMUNITY AND I
ASSURE THAT TO SAY THAT. IF
LATINOS ARE THE LARGEST
DEMOGRAPHIC IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THE FASTEST GROWING
IN THE NATION. ANYTHING THAT
IMPACTS LET THE NOT. IMPACTS
THE AMERICAN PUBLIC. AND SO AN
ISSUE THAT IS A LATINA ISSUE IS
AN AMERICAN ISSUE. AND WE
SHOULD THINK ABOUT IT IN TERMS
OF HOW DO WE ENSURE THAT THIS
POPULATION IS SUCCESSFUL. IN
ITS- IN THE OPPORTUNITIES THAT
ARE CURRENTLY AVAILABLE. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU I'M. DR GRANT
DELAY YOU HAVE A QUESTION.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
REALLY I'M GLAD TO BE ABLE TO
JOIN YOU TODAY THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY. I'M WANTED TO
AND BEFORE I FORGET I JUST WANT
TO SAY HELLO TO THE SILVER
MEDAL ONE OF MY HEROES AND A
REAL CHAMPION FOR HER FROM
WORKING COMMUNITY. MY QUESTION
FOR TODAY IS GOING TO BE FOR
DOCTOR MUST. LOOKING AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA MERCED
PAPER WANTED TO GIVE YOU AN
OPPORTUNITY TO TALK ABOUT
POLICY ACTIONS OR SOLUTIONS. AS
YOU STATE THAT THE POLICY
RESPONSES ARE NEEDED TO PREVENT
ADVERSE HEALTH AND ECONOMIC.
OUTCOMES AND BEFORE YOU BEGIN
ON THE- BOX THAT YOU HAVE I
REALLY WANT TO JUST MENTION I
KNOW WERE IN CALIFORNIA AND OUR
STATE HOUSE. BUT IMMIGRATION
REFORM IS THE NUMBER ONE POLICY
REVIEW RECOMMENDATION THAT MANY
OF US HAVE BEEN ADVOCATING FOR
YEARS IF NOT DECADES. THAT
WOULD BE ABLE TO HELP OUR
LATINOS AND LATINOS REALLY
WANTED TO TALK IF I COULD ABOUT
FOUR HAVE YOU COMMENT ABOUT THE
GOLDEN STATE STIMULUS
SPECIFICALLY EITC AND I TENS.
THAT OUR MAJORITY LEADER
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RAY AS
CHAMPIONS LAST YEAR TO SEE IF
THAT CAN BE INCLUSIVE AND IS
WHAT YOU ARE TALKING ABOUT WITH
PRIORITIZING AND COME SUPPORT.
DR MACIAS. AT I JUST WANT TO
CLARIFY THAT THE UC MERCED
PAPER WAS WRITTEN BY DIFFERENT
PANELS FOR THE NEXT PANEL BUT
YOUR QUESTION I THINK STILL
RELEVANT. THAT THE NEXT PANEL
WILL GET THE AUTHOR FOR THE ON.
FAIR ENOUGH- DR MACIAS. I WILL
YES IT'S NOT MY OF MY PAPER BUT
I WILL COMMENT THAT- WE HAVE
SEEN. THAT IN AS OF MAY TWENTY
TWENTY- WE SAW THAT AS PEOPLE
AS WOMEN WERE LOSING THEIR JOBS
IT WAS THE IMMIGRANTS WHO LOST
THE GREATEST NUMBER OF
JOBSEEKERS PERCENTAGE THEY WERE
THE ONES THAT WERE THE MOST
IMPACTED BY THE JOB LOSSES
IMMEDIATELY AFTER THE PANDEMIC
STARTED EACH AND THOSE ARE THE
SAME. PEOPLE WHO ALSO DID NOT
HAVE ACCESS THEY DIDN'T HAVE
THE SAFETY NET BUT OTHERS ARE
OTHERS DEBT SO THEY DIDN'T HAVE
ACCESS TO UNEMPLOYMENT
INSURANCE- AND THEY DIDN'T HAVE
ACCESS TO- TO- THE STIMULUS
MONIES SO I MEAN CAN YOU
IMAGINE IS. IT AS AS MISTRUST
AND YOU LOOK WHICH WAS WITH
SPEAKING AND MY HEART GOES OUT
TO YOU BUT CAN YOU IMAGINE IF
YOU DIDN'T HAVE. YOUR CHECK ON
TOP OF EVERY ELSE SO I THINK
IT'S EXTREMELY CRUCIAL AS
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT GETTING
ACCESS TO THOSE- THE EXTENT I
TENS- YOU KNOW WE NEED TO BE
ABLE TO BE AT REACHING OUT. TO
THE PEOPLE WHO ALREADY DO
QUALIFY IN MAKING SURE THAT
THEY CAN GET THOSE. THOSE THAT
THAT. AT STATUS SO THAT THEY
CAN GET ACCESS TO DUE TO THE
SAFETY NET BENEFITS. AND THEN
ALSO WHEN YOU JUST CONSIDER YOU
KNOW EXPANDING. WHO DOES
QUALIFY FOR THAT- SO YOU KNOW
THERE ARE THERE ARE SO MANY
LEVELS AND WE NEED- IN IN I
KNOW MY RESEARCH WE'VE
IDENTIFIED THAT THERE ARE LIKE
THE S. WE'VE DONE EXTREMELY
WELL- WHO HAVE NOT BEEN. HEARD
AS MUCH BY THE PANDEMICS ARE A
FAX AND- AND THEN THERE ARE
THOSE IN THE MIDDLE WHO ARE YOU
KNOW OR- YOU KNOW. HAVING TO
MAKE MAYBE A FEW CHANGES BUT
STILL NOT IMPACTED WE'RE WITH
THEM THERE'S JUST TREMENDOUS.
PORTION OF THE- POPULATION IS
WITH OURS ALSO I MEAN IT'S A
HUGE NUMBER WHO ARE AFFECTING
THE BOTTOM LINE FOR THE ENTIRE
CALIFORNIA'S ECONOMY. SO WHAT
ARE WE DOING TO MAKE SURE THAT
THOSE WOMEN WHO ARE YOU KNOW. I
THINK THAT ARE SORT OF MESSAGE
THEY'RE ALREADY RESPONSIBLE FOR
FEEDING US THEY'RE ALREADY
RESPONSIBLE NOW FOR TEACHING
THEIR CHILDREN SO A SO THE FACT
THAT WE ARE NOT DOING MORRIS.
IS FRANKLY TOWN CONSCIONABLE.
IF I COULD I OPPOSE. FOR MIX
THE TWO PANELS BUT OFTENTIMES
BOTH THE ACT AND HEALTH IMPACTS
ARE TIED THE SOCIAL
DETERMINANTS OF HEALTH THAT
WERE SPOKEN ABOUT. AND THEN
THAT I JUST WANT TO UPLIFT THE
COMMENT FROM THE TULARE COUNTY
RESIDENT WHO SAID. RIGHT NOW WE
DIE OF HUNGER OR WE DIE OF THE
VIRUS. FOR THOSE WHO ARE HAVING
TO MAKE THOSE TOUGH CHOICES
ABOUT MAKING. AND PUTTING FOOD
ON THE ROUND TABLE THAT THOSE
CHOICES BETWEEN ECONOMICS AND
HEALTH ARE TIED. AND SO WE HAVE
TO FIGURE OUT HOW WE ARE
PROVIDING SOLUTIONS SO WE CAN
GET BETTER RESULTS AND- NOT
CONTINUE TO HAVE LATINOS AND
LATINOS DISPROPORTIONATELY
IMPACTED BY THIS PANDEMIC.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU
MISTRESS. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR.
I OFTENTIMES I HERE AND WE'VE
HEARD FROM OUR PANELISTS HOW WE
NEED TO COLLECT DATA WE NEED TO
DO A NUMBER OF THINGS. WE ALL
RECOGNIZE THIS AND I THINK
FINDING THE RIGHT ORGANIZATIONS
TO DO THIS IS EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT. UP LIFTING THESE
ORGANIZATIONS THAT HAVE THAT
CAPACITY. IS EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT AND I THINK THAT WE
AS LEGISLATORS WE WE'RE WE'RE
GOING TO BE ON THE SAME PAGE WE
WANT THESE THINGS DONE. BUT
IT'S FINDING THE RIGHT. THE
RIGHT ORGANIZATION TO PUT TO
THE FOREFRONT IS EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT. SO I WOULD ASK OUR
PANELISTS. THAT IF THERE ARE
THESE. INSTITUTIONS ALREADY
THESE ORGANIZATIONS THAT HAVE
THAT CAPACITY. I ALSO TO PLEASE
PROVIDE THAT TO OUR CHAIR- THE
IT IS MAKING SURE THAT AS WE
MAKE OUR REQUEST IN OUR DEMANDS
FOR MORE INCLUSIVE DATA
COLLECTION MORE EAT BETTER
EVALUATION OF THE DATA. THAT WE
ARE ABLE TO SAY AND HERE IS THE
ORGANIZATION THIS IS THE
INSTITUTION THAT HAS THE
CAPACITY TO DO THIS IN A PROPER
WAY. BECAUSE WE'RE ALL GOING TO
AGREE WITH A COMMENT MORE NEEDS
TO BE DONE. WE WANT TO BE MORE
SPECIFIC ABOUT HOW WE GET
THINGS DONE. I- I ALSO WANT TO
TAKE A MOMENT TO THANK CENTER
LOCUS OF MS LOPEZ THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR SHARING YOUR PERSONAL
STORY IT MAKES A DIFFERENCE
WHEN WE'RE TRYING TO TALK ABOUT
POLICIES BECAUSE WHEN WE HEAR
FROM THE VOICES OF THOSE WHO
ARE MOST AFFECTED NOT THOSE OF
US WHO STUDIED NOT THOSE OF US
WHO HEAR ABOUT IT NOT THOSE OF
US WHO SEE IT BUT THOSE WHO
ACTUALLY EXPERIENCE IT THOSE
ARE THE THOSE ARE THE WORDS
THAT ARE MOST IMPORTANT TO US
SO- MS LOPEZ THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR SHARING. MISTER KALRA.
THANK YOU MANAGER AND I AND I
AGREE COMPLETELY WITH THE
SUMMER REYES IN TERMS OF THE
DATA AND I KNOW- THE PROFESSOR
LOPEZ MADE REFERENCE TO IT AND
HOW DIFFICULT IT CAN BE TO GET.
GOOD DATA BECAUSE IF WE DON'T
HAVE GOOD DATA THEN WE CAN
LEAVE THIS BUILDING FEELING
GOOD LIKE WE'RE DOING THE RIGHT
THING IN GETTING RESOURCES OUT
THERE. BUT IT DOESN'T REDUCE
THE SMALL BUSINESS OF THE NEED
TO HELP THE FAMILIES THAT NEED
HELP THE WORKERS NEED THE HELP
AND SO. AGREE A 100% THAT WE
NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT AS THIS-
COMMITTEE GOES FORWARD THAT.
EVERYONE THAT IS GOING TO BE A
ROGUE WONDERFUL SENATE PANELS
HERE OTHER THEY FEEL FREE TO
CONTINUE THE DIALOGUE AND SEND
INFORMATION TO US AND KEEP US
FULLY INFORMED BECAUSE- WE
KNOW. THAT THE INFORMATION WE
GET IS ON DEPEND ON WHAT YOU
CAN YOU TELL US ON THE GROUND.
AND I WOULD LIKE TO JUST- YEAH.
BECAUSE PRESENT TODAY A ROOM-
WHO WHO. REFERRED TO. YOU KNOW
IF YOU LOOK AT THE CALL THE
DEATH RATES AMONG THE HIGHEST
OUR- COOKS SO THOSE ARE
WORKING. FAST FOOD RESTAURANTS
AND OTHER RESTAURANTS ALLOWING
SO MANY OF US. TO BE ABLE TO
STAY HOME. FARMWORKERS ALSO
RIGHT UP THERE AS WELL. AND SO
I KNOW OUR OUR CHAIR AND OTHERS
HAVE BEEN. WILL PUSH FOR. MORE
PAID SICK LEAVE AND I WAS
SOMETHING THAT. I'M NOT PRESENT
ROMERO MADE REFERENCE TO. BUT
SHE ALSO MADE REFERENCE-
TOWARDS THE END OF OUR COMMENTS
REGARDING. THE CHANGING
VACCINATION RULES. AND THE
CONFUSION IT CREATES AND HOW
CAN INTENSELY LEAVE PEOPLE OUT.
AND SO I DON'T KNOW IF- IS
PRESIDENT OF ROMERO WOULD LIKE
TO. COMMENT ON THAT BCAUSE I
ALSO HAVE GREAT CONCERNS ABOUT
THAT AS WE CHANGE THE RULES.
THAT WERE NOT ACTUALLY GETTING
THE AND WE DO KNOW. THAT
FARMERS NEED TO GET BACK SENATE
THEY'RE THE ONES THAT ARE DYING
THEY'RE THE ONES THAT ARE AGAIN
ARE A CENTRAL FOR ALL OF US.
AND SO ARE THERE ANY THOUGHTS
NOW THAT THESE TOOLS AND CHANGE
WHAT WE CAN DO TO ENSURE
ESPECIALLY THOSE LIKE YOU KNOW
WE HAVE OUR- OUR CULTURE OF.
SURVEILLANCE WE HAVE SOME
ARAMBULA ANOTHER IS THAT THE
WORK VERY CLOSELY WITH OUR
FARMWORKERS. AND SO IF THERE'S
ANY FURTHER THOUGHT ON THAT.
COMMENT THAT WAS MADE ON HOW WE
CAN MAKE SURE THE VACCINES ARE
GETTING TO ESSENTIAL WORKERS.
AND THIS CASE QUICKLY
FARMWORKERS. OKAY FALL JUST
ABOUT AS A COMMENT AND WE CAN
ALWAYS FOLLOW UP WITH. YES SIR
SO- PRESENT REMEMBER I THINK
NEEDED TO CATCH A FLIGHT- SO
SHE- HOW TO MOVE ON BUT THAT IS
A- NOTED COMMENT- I HAVE IT'S
NOT SO MUCH A QUESTION- FOR
CYNTHIA. IT HER STORY- AS HEART
WRENCHING IT IS IT IS REMINDS
ME THOUGH WHAT WE TALKED ABOUT
RE ENTRY INTO THE WORK FORCE
AND I KNOW THAT. I AM HOPEFUL
THAT CYNTHIA WILL BE ABLE TO GO
BACK TO HER JOB AT THE SAN
DIEGO- BAYFRONT HILTON BECAUSE
SAN DIEGO HAS PAID HAS PASSED A
RETENTION ORDINANCE A RECALL
ORDINANCE. THAT MEANS THAT-
WHEN THAT JOB IS AVAILABLE AT
THANKS TO HER UNION AND THIS
ORDINANCE SHE WILL HAVE A SHOT
AT GETTING BACK INTO THE WORK
FORCE AT THE SAME LEVEL AS SHE
LEFT IT. I'M WONDERING FOR THE-
ACADEMIC PANELISTS YOU KNOW HW
IMPORTANT WHEN WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT RECOVERY IS BEING ABLE TO
RETURN AS CALIFORNIA OPENS UP
TO THE SAME JOB AT LEAST- OR
BETTER FOR AN INDIVIDUAL AND
LEVINE IS THAT HOW IMPORTANT IS
THAT FEATURE I MEAN THAT'S
SOMETHING WE HAVEN'T SEEN DIEGO
AND LARGE CITIES LOS ANGELES I
THINK- A NUMBER OF LARGE CITIES
BUT IT'S NOT UNIVERSAL FOR THE
STATE. I WILL I WILL SAY THAT
IT'S REALLY CRITICAL I MEAN.
STARTING ANY NEW JOB IS
DIFFICULT AND IT TAKES A LOT OF
EFFORTS YOU HAVE TO YOU MAY
NEED NEW TRAINING SO BEING ABLE
TO HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO GO
BACK TO THAT JOB AND CERTAINLY
IF YOU HAVE A BETTER.
BETTER JOB EVEN BETTER- BUT
ALSO WITH THE OPPORTUNITY TO
GET INTO JOBS THAT HAVE
BENEFITS THAT HAVE- YOU KNOW
HOW THE SAFETY. PROTOCOLS IN
PLACE IS ALSO ESSENTIAL I MEAN
THIS THIS IS THIS IS A HARD
LESSON FOR ALL OF US TO LEARN
BUT IT DOESN'T NECESSARILY MEAN
IT THIS IS THE OF THE LAST
PANDEMIC WILL BE FACING. AND
EVEN EVEN BEFORE THE PANDEMIC
ISSUES IT ALSO DOESN'T MEAN
THAT THEIR WORK EXISTING HEALTH
AND SAFETY ISSUES. SO YOU KNOW
BEING ABLE TO BEING ABLE TO
HAVE OPTIONS IS EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT FOR WOMEN- THE OTHER
ISSUE IS YOU KNOW. AS WE
MENTIONED CHILD CARE. WOMEN TO
HAVE THE GREATER BRANCH OF THE
CHILD CARE AVERAGING AND
TEACHING THEIR CHILDREN SO.
HAVING BE ABLE TO GO BACK TO A
JOB IT'S GOING TO TAKE THAT
INTO CONSIDERATION THAT MAY.
MAKE SOME CHILDCARE
ALTERNATIVES POSSIBLE OR THAT.
PROVIDE ENOUGH. OF A- LIVING
WAGE THAT WILL PROVIDE- YOU
KNOW JUST LEFT OVER TO PAY. FOR
CHILD CARE IS ALSO REALLY
IMPORTANT. THANK YOU. I JUST TO
ECHO- I TALK TO SEE IF INSIDE
THE THINK IT'S VERY IF YOU CAN
BACK TO THAT JOB BUT IF THE JOB
WAS GREAT TO BEGIN WITH. IT'S
NOT REALLY GOING TO HELP AND I
AND I THINK WE WANT TO THINK
ABOUT THIS. AS AN OPPORTUNITY
TO THINK. ABOUT IT JUST AND
EQUITABLE RECOVERY SO AS WE
COME OUT OF THIS. WHAT DO WE
WANT TO DO IN TERMS OF RE
SKILLING. IN TERMS OF YOU KNOW
JOB TRAINING- FOR LATINOS
BECAUSE I THINK THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT. IF WE WANT TO MOVE
THEM INTO BETTER PAYING JOBS WE
SEE THE OCCUPATIONAL
SEGREGATION. THAT IS VERY MUCH
AGAIN ALSO YOU KNOW BECAUSE OF
DISCRIMINATION IN THE LABOR
MARKET- BUT I THINK WE WANT TO
THINK ABOUT HOW DO WE REDUCE
STOCKS SEGREGATION SO THAT. AS
DOCTORS YES I'VE NEVER COME
DEMOCRATS ANOTHER DOWNTURN.
IT'S NOT THOSE SAME WORKERS IN
THOSE SAME INDUSTRIES AND
OCCUPATIONS ARE TO KEEP GETTING
AT. SO I THINK WE NEED TO THINK
BIGGER ABOUT. YOU KNOW ME
MOVING BEYOND THOSE THOSE JOBS
THAT MANY OF THESE LATINOS HAVE
INTO. SOMETHING BETTER. YEAH
I'M THANK YOU I WILL NOTE THAT
AS A GOOD UNION. JOBS AND I'M
IN IT FOR A HOTEL IS WITH
BENEFITS AND- A LIVING WAGES IS
A- IS GOOD- WE DON'T I JUST
WANT AYE I'LL PUSH BACK A
LITTLE BIT ON THOSE STATEMENTS
BECAUSE THE SUGGESTION THAT
SOMEHOW WE'RE GONNA COME OUT OF
THE PANDEMIC AND- RETRAIN
PEOPLE FOR JOBS THAT AREN'T
SERVICE SECTOR JOBS THAT ARE
COMING OUT OF WHEN WE'RE SIMPLY
ASKING FOR- INDIVIDUALS WHO
HAVE LOST THEIR JOB TO BE AT
LEAST GET BACK ON THEIR FEET
WITH IT ESPECIALLY IF THEY HAD
A GOOD SERVICE SECTOR JOBS THAT
INCLUDED HEALTH CARE THAT
INCLUDED A LIVING WAGE INCLUDED
MAYBE A LITTLE BIT IN
RETIREMENT. I THINK- I I'D I'D
NEVER WANT TO SUGGEST THAT WERE
WERE SAYING THAT THAT'S NOT A
GOOD JOB- THOSE THEY SHOULD BE
BETTER- BUT IT IT'S NOT
EXACTLY- THE LOWEST ROUND. TO
SAY THE LEAST. MMHM ASSEMBLY.
I'M SURE ONE. CYNTHIA THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR SHARING YOUR STORY
WITH US I THINK IT IT TOUCHED
ALL OF US AND- WE FEEL FOR YOU
AND I AM PARTICULARLY CONCERNED
WITH THE REGRESSION THAT ARE
SPECIAL NEEDS STUDENTS ARE
FEELING THROUGH THIS PANDEMIC
AND I'M ALSO PARTICULARLY
CONCERNED THAT. WHAT'S GOING ON
DIAGNOSIS THIS PAST YEAR AND
THERE'S GONNA BE A DOMINO
EFFECT THAT WE WILL GET TO SEE
FOR YEARS TO COME AS WE START
TO ADDRESS THIS ISSUE SO THANK
YOU FOR SHARING YOUR STORY. MY
FAMILY CAME TO THE UNITED
STATES SO MY DAD'S SIDE IN
NINETEEN ELEVEN TO NINETEEN
SEVENTEEN FROM MEXICO. THE
CAMERA CALIFORNIA SPECIFICALLY
FOR OPPORTUNITY MY GREAT
GRANDPARENTS MY GRANDPARENTS MY
DOT ALL WORKED THE FIELDS AND
THE CENTRAL VALLEY MY
GRANDMOTHER WORKED ALONGSIDE
SAYS ARE CHAVEZ. AND THE
CALIFORNIA THAT MY FAMILY CAME
TO THE GOLDEN CALIFORNIA THE
OPPORTUNITIES THEY CAME HERE
FOR. OUR DWINDLING DESPITE
THEIR GRANDDAUGHTER SITTING
HERE IN THE STATE ASSEMBLY AS
AN ELECTED OFFICIAL. WE HAVE
GOT TO ADDRESS THE ECONOMIC
POLICIES IN CALIFORNIA THAT ARE
DRIVING LATINOS AND LATINO
FAMILIES OUT OF CALIFORNIA. THE
HIGH COST OF LIVING THE LACK OF
ACCESS TO QUALITY CHILDCARE. I
THINK PART OF WHAT WE CAN DO TO
ADDRESS THESE ISSUES AND I HAVE
TWO QUESTIONS FOR YOU HERE
THOUGH. IT'S TAKE A SERIOUS
LOOK AT ONE OF MY BIGGEST
PRIORITIES WHICH IS CHILD CARE
AND ACCESS TO QUALITY
PRESCHOOL. WE HAVE TO ENSURE
THAT THE LATINO WORK FORCE HAS
ACCESS TO TOP QUALITY CHILD
CARE BUT WE ALSO HAVE TO
RECOGNIZE THAT THEY ARE THE
PROVIDERS AS WELL THEY'RE SMALL
BUSINESS OWNERS. THIS INDUSTRY
IS LOOKING AT LOSING A THIRD TO
HALF OF THIS INDUSTRY AND THESE
ARE NOT THE NOT BUSINESS
OWNERS. WHAT IN YOUR OPINION
CAN WE BE DOING TO PROMOTE SO
WE HAVE TO ADDRESS THAT ISSUE
THE SECOND QUESTION WHEN I'M
OPPOSE HERE. IS WHAT CAN WE BE
DOING TO PROMOTE FINANCIAL
LITERACY ESPECIALLY FOR YOUNG
LATINAS TO ENSURE THAT THEY
HAVE THE TOOLS TO DEVELOP.
THEIR OWN FINANCIAL STRATEGIES
FOR THEIR LIVES AND FOR THEIR
FAMILIES. AND MY SECOND
QUESTION IS WHAT PERCENTAGE OF
LETTING OUR BUSINESSES AND THIS
IS- HOPEFULLY DR LOPEZ HAS SOME
OF THIS INFORMATION. WHAT
PERCENTAGE OF THE LEADING A
BUSINESS OWNERS R. S. CERT
RECEIVE GOVERNMENT CONTRACTS
AND HOW CAN WE HELP THEM TO BE
MORE COMPETITIVE ESPECIALLY IN
THEIR START UP PHASES. THANKS
SO REAL QUICK BEFORE I GO ON
CLARIFY I WILL I WAS IN THIS IS
HARDLY SEEN PREVIOUS COMMENT
THAT THOSE JOBS WERE BAD. YES
THERE ARE GREAT JOBS I WAS JUST
SAYING IT'S AN OPPORTUNITY TO
STILL REACH THINK ABOUT
RETRAINING AND SEE HOW WE COULD
MOVE THOSE THAT DON'T HAVE
THOSE UNIONIZED JOBS AND DON'T
HAVE THOSE. JOBS WITH BENEFITS
FOR IT- GOING BACK TO YOUR
QUESTION ABOUT
ENTREPRENEURSHIP- I THINK YOU
KNOW IN TERMS OF YOUR FINANCIAL
LITERACY I THINK THAT'S
IMPORTANT. I THINK PARTNERING
YOU KNOW WITH LOCAL BANKS I
THINK GETTING LOCAL BANKS TO
TAKE. A BIGGER ROLE IN IN
PREDOMINANTLY LATINO
COMMUNITIES ARE LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES AND STRENGTHENING
THOSE PARTNERSHIPS CAN CAN BE A
WAY TO INCREASE THAT FINANCIAL
LITERACY- I THINK IN TERMS OF.
YOU KNOW I DON'T KNOW ACTUALLY
TO BE HONEST ANSWER TO THE
QUESTION HOW MANY OF THEM- ARE
ARE OF THE- SMALL BUSINESS
ASSOCIATION R RECEIVE
GOVERNMENT CONTRACTS- I DON'T
ACTUALLY HAVE THAT DONE UP ON
HIM AND- BUT I THINK IT'S VERY
IMPORTANT CHIU CHOI KIND OF
SUPPORT. DOES ENTREPRENEURIAL
EFFORTS AND I THINK THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT AGAIN YOU KNOW
THE WORKING WITH THOSE LOCAL
ORGANIZATIONS TO FIND. IN A
WAYS WHERE THEY CAN CONNECT TO
REALLY SEE WHAT THE STRUGGLES
OF LATINO BUSINESS OWNERS ARE-
I THINK THERE IS AGAIN THE BIG
ACCESS TO FINANCIAL CAPITAL IS
DISCRIMINATION THAT THEY FACED
WHEN THEY'RE LYING- THERE IS
YOU KNOW I'M ALSO THEY DON'T.
FEEL NECESSARILY COMFORTABLE.
WORKING WITH THE BANKS BECAUSE
BANKS SOMETIMES PLAY A VERY
SMALL ROLE IN OUR COMMUNITY. SO
INCREASING THAT RELATIONSHIP
WITH LOCAL BANKS COULD SORT OF
INCREASE TRUST AND COULD LEAD
TO MORE OPPORTUNITIES ON AND
ACCESS. TO FINANCIAL CAPITAL.
IF I COULD JUST ADD TO THE LOOK.
COMMENTS HOPE- I DID US. FOCUS
GROUP STUDY HOPE WERE I. ENTER.
AND ARE. AT SPOKE WITH SEVERAL
MICRO BUSINESS ON. IN CITIES OF
THE STATE AND WE DID FIND
EXACTLY WHAT DOCTOR LOOK AS
MENTIONED BUT WE ALSO AND IN
ADDITION TO THAT FOUND THAT-
BUT- MICHAEL LET THE AMERICAN
BUSINESS OWNERS. AREN'T ALWAYS
PREPARED. TO BE ABLE TO MAKE
THE MOST OF SOME OF THE
OPPORTUNITIES SO THEY MAY BE
AWARE THERE MAY BE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR THEM TO GET
THE ARM. TO GET MORE
INFORMATION TO GET EDUCATED
ABOUT THESE ISSUES BUT IT MIGHT
BE ACROSS TOWN SO THEY'RE IN
THE SAN DIEGO AREA OR THE LOS
ANGELES AREA AND IT GOT TO GET.
ALL THE WAY ACROSS TOWN WHEN
THEY'RE ALREADY PUTTING IN. A
FULL TIME. JOB AND THEN THEY
COME HOME MAKE DINNER AND THEN
THEY YOU KNOW SPEND TWO OR
THREE HOURS ON THEIR- THEIR-
MICRO BUSINESS. FOR SOMEONE TO
SUGGEST THAT THEY ALWAYS YOU
KNOW THERE ARE PLENTY OF
RESOURCES YOU JUST HAVE TO GET
THEIR TO GO AN HOUR THERE. NO
TWO HOURS FOR THE TRAINING AND
THEN AND THEN COME HOME AND
START THE WHOLE THING AGAIN.
THAT CAN BE CHALLENGING IN
ADDITION TO THAT WE FOUND THAT
A LOT OF THE WOMEN ARE SIMPLY
DON'T HAVE IT YOU KNOW THEY
MIGHT HAVE BIG IDEAS BUT THEY
HAVEN'T. THEY DON'T HAVE A
WRITTEN BUSINESS PLAN THEY
DON'T HAVE ALL THE DOCUMENTS
THAT ARE THAT THE BANKS ARE
GOING TO BE ASKING THEM FOR
WHEN THEY COME IN. WHEN THEY
FINALLY GET THE NERVE TO
CONNECT YOU TO THE BANKS BANKS
YOU CAN EXPECT THEM TO HAVE A
LOT OF INFORMATION THAT THEY
JUST DON'T HAPPEN. SO THERE ARE
OPPORTUNITIES ARE LOTS OF
OPPORTUNITIES FOR LATINOS TO
GET. THOSE DOCUMENTS IN ORDER
BUT THEY HAVE TO BE ABLE TO GET
THERE- IN ADDITION TO THAT-
HOPE DOES. HOST OF FINANCIAL
LITERACY CONVENING THROUGHOUT
THE YEAR EVERY YEAR IN
DIFFERENT CITIES. AND. THERE IS
A DEMAND FOR THAT. ALBUM IS
THAT THERE'S THE GROUP DEMAND
SO- THAT YOU'VE GOT EVERYONE. A
FIVE YOU OLD READ COLLEGE GRAD.
OF WHO MAY. YOU'RE STILL TRYING
TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO DO SOME
BASIC BUDGETING SITTING NEXT TO
A- YOU KNOW. A WOMAN WHO'S
APPROACHING FORTY WITH YEAH
THREE OR FOUR KIDS AND YOU KNOW
WAS TRYING TO. MANAGE THEIR
BEYOND. THE BUDGET FOR AN
ENTIRE HOUSEHOLD SITTING NEXT
TO A WOMAN WHO IS MAYBE YOU
KNOW. HAS A LARGER INCOME MORE
DISPOSABLE INCOME AND HER
QUESTIONS MIGHT BE REALLY NOT
ABOUT BASIC BUDGETING BUT
ABOUT. THE DIFFERENT STRATEGIES
TO- TO INCREASE HER RETIREMENT
ACCOUNT OR EMAIL THE BEST WAYS
TO THINK ABOUT. RETIRING DID
SHE PUT HOW MUCH MONEY AYE
REVERSES YOU KNOW FIRST OF THE
DIFFERENT PRODUCT. SO YOU KNOW
THERE'S THIS TREMENDOUS NEED
AND YOU KNOW IT'S HARD TO BE
ABLE TO- TO ADDRESS ALL OF THAT
NEED IN YEAH ONE. WHEN YOU HAVE
JUST ONE OPPORTUNITY- SO
THERE'S A TREMENDOUS NEED BUT
WE ALSO THINK ABOUT HOW TO
MATCH UP. THE OPPORTUNITIES FOR
LEARNING WITH WHERE. THE WOMEN
ARE AND WHAT THEIR NEEDS ARE.
THANK YOU. I'M THANK YOU I'M
GONNA GO WITH LET'S I'M WORRIED
WE'RE GOING TO OUT OF TIME THIS
IS OBVIOUSLY THE ECONOMIC
IMPACTS ARE HUGE I ANTICIPATE
WILL BE- RELYING ON SOME OF
THESE- IN ALL OF THESE WOMEN-
IN THE FUTURE FOR TRYING TO
COME UP WITH SOME POLICY
PROPOSALS THAT REALLY GET OUT-
HOW WE- HOW WE ADDRESS THIS
COMING OUT OF. OUT OF THE
PANDEMIC BUT WE ALSO KNOW THAT
THE PANDEMIC OBVIOUSLY HAS HAD
HEALTH EFFECTS HEALTH EFFECTS
ON LATINAS IN PARTICULAR AND
SO. WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON NOW TO
THE SECOND GROUP OF PANELISTS.
FIRST WE'LL HEAR FROM OTHER
JANAB RAMOS. YEAH I'M A MODEL.
I HOPE WE CAN GET PULL HER UP.
A POLICY ANALYST WITH THE
CALIFORNIA BUDGET AND POLICY
CENTER OTHER ANNA. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF THIS
COMMITTEE GOOD AFTERNOON
EVERYONE MY NAME IS ADRIANA I'M
POLICY ANALYST AT THE
CALIFORNIA BUDGET AND POLICY
CENTER. IF YOU'RE NOT FAMILIAR
WITH OUR WORK WE ENGAGE IN
INDEPENDENT FISCAL AND POLICY
ANALYSIS AND PUBLIC EDUCATION
WITH THE GOAL OF IMPROVING THE
ECONOMIC AND SOCIAL WELL BEING
OF CALIFORNIANS WITH LOW AND
MIDDLE INCOMES. OUR VISION IS
FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS TO
PARTICIPATE IN THE STATE'S
ECONOMIC SOCIAL AND POLITICAL
LIFE. I'M HERE TODAY TO TALK
ABOUT THE IMPACT OF THE OTHER
NINETEEN PANDEMIC ON
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR
HIGHLIGHTING LATIN NEXT
CALIFORNIANS AND HOW WE GOT
THERE. I SHOULD MENTION WE DO
HAVE A REPORT COMING OUT IN A
FEW WEEKS ON THIS TOPIC SO
PLEASE STAY TUNED FOR THAT YOU
CAN SIGN UP FOR OUR UPDATES.
OUR WEBSITE CAL BUDGET CENTER
.ORG. AS WE APPROACH ALMOST A
YEAR INTO THE PANDEMIC OVER
THREE POINT ONE MILLION
CALIFORNIANS HAVE TESTED
POSITIVE FOR COLBERT NINETEEN.
AND OVER THIRTY EIGHT THOUSAND
PEOPLE HAVE DIED DUE TO THE
VIRUS. THESE ARE FAMILY MEMBERS
FRIENDS FRONTLINE WORKERS AND
MEMBERS OF OUR COMMUNITIES WHO
ARE GETTING SICK AND ARE DYING.
THIS IS A DEVASTATING LOSS AND
UNFORTUNATELY IT'S NOT THE ONLY
DISPARITIES FACING PEOPLE OF
COLOR AT MID AMID THE PANDEMIC.
AS YOU ALL KNOW OR HAVE HEARD
BY NOW THE VIRUS IS
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTING
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR. LET THE
NEXT CALIFORNIANS ARE
ESPECIALLY HARD HIT. THE
ACCOUNT FOR NEARLY 55% OF
CASES. IN 46% OF DEATHS YET
THEY REPRESENT JUST AROUND 39%
OF THE STATE'S POPULATION. I'M
GOING TO SHOW YOU ALSO THE
CHARTS MY COLLEAGUE MONICA
DOUGLAS AND I HAVE PUT TOGETHER
HI I LIKE THESE RACIAL. THE
DATA ABOUT A WEEK OLD BUT WILL
STILL HELP US TO UNDERSTAND THE
IMPACT ON COMMUNITIES OF COLOR-
DILLON FULL. THE UP. WE HAVE AN
APPOINTMENT WE'VE BEEN HAVING
PROBLEMS SEEN CHARTS SO YOU MAY
HAVE TO JUST TALK US THROUGH IT.
IF THAT'S POSSIBLE NO PROBLEM.
I THINK I AM THE- CAN YOU ALL.
NOW OKAY GREAT I THINK THE
NODDING HEADS. OKAY SO THIS
CHART SHOWS COPA NINETY IN CASE
RATES BY RACE ETHNICITY THAT
ARE ADJUSTED FOR AGE AS YOU CAN
SEE A NATIVE HAWAIIAN AND OTHER-PACIFIC ISLANDER CALIFORNIANS
HAVE THE HIGHEST RATE OF COVERT
NINETEEN INFECTIONS FOLLOWED BY
A LOT NEXT CALIFORNIANS THERE
ARE A LOT OF DIFFERENT FACTORS
FOR WHY RECINE THIS SOME PEOPLE
OF COLOR HAVE HIGHER RISK OF
INFECTION PARTLY BECAUSE THEY
ARE MORE LIKELY TO WORK IN
ESSENTIAL SERVICES. LIVE IN
MULTI GENERATIONAL HOMES AND
LACK ACCESS TO WORK BETTER
THAT'S THAT ALLOWED ME TO STAY
HOME IF THEY'RE SICK. THIS NEXT
CHART SHOWS CODE NINETY THREE
CALORIES BY RACE ETHNICITY THAT
ARE ALSO ADJUSTED FOR AGE. JUST
AS YOU SAW IN THE CASE RATES
RACIAL DISPARITIES ARE APPARENT
IN KOBE NINETEEN DEATH RATES.
YOU COULD SEE THAT LATIN NEXT
NEED OF HAWAIIAN AND OTHER
PACIFIC ISLANDER AND BLACK
CALIFORNIANS EXPERIENCE THE
HIGHEST RATES OF DEATH DUE TO
CULVERT NINETEEN. THESE
DISPARITIES ARE ALARMING
CONSIDERING THAT THE LOT NEXT
POPULATION IS GENERALLY YOUNGER
THAN SOME OF THE OTHER
DEMOGRAPHIC GROUPS YEAH ARE
DYING FROM COVERT NINETEEN AT
SUCH HIGH RATES. AND T'S
IMPORTANT TO TAKE AGE INTO
CONSIDERATION BECAUSE THE RISK
FOR SEVERE ILLNESS AND EVEN
DEATH FROM COVERT NINETEEN
INCREASES AS A PERSON THEN GETS
OLDER. WE ALSO KNOW THAT SOME
CALIFORNIA COLOR HAVE HIGHER
RATES OF UNDERLYING HEALTH
CONDITIONS AND HAVE LESS ACCESS
TO HEALTH COVERAGE. FOR
INSTANCE LET NEXT CALIFORNIANS
ARE MORE LIKELY TO REPORT FAIR
OR POOR HEALTH AND TO BE
UNINSURED. ABOUT ONE IN FIVE
LATIN NEXT CALIFORNIANS DID NOT
HAVE A USUAL SOURCE OF CARE AND
ONE IN SIX EXPERIENCE
DIFFICULTY FINDING A SPECIALIST.
EVEN BEFORE THE PANDEMIC LACK
OF ACCESSIBLE AND QUALITY
HEALTH CARE COVERAGE. ENTERED A
LOT OF PEOPLE FROM RECEIVING
PROPOFOL PREVENTIVE CARE
TREATMENT FOR CHRONIC DISEASES
AND SEEKING TREATMENT WHEN
NEEDED DUE TO THE COST. WE ALSO
KNOW THAT LATIN NEXT ADULTS AS
WELL AS BLACK AND AMERICAN
INDIAN ADULTS EXPERIENCE HIGHER
RATES OF OBESITY IN CALIFORNIA
AND HAVING OF CITY IS
CONSIDERED TO BE A RISK FACTOR
FOR SEVERE ILLNESS. FROM COVERT
NINETEEN. AND IF WE COULD TAKE
ONE STEP BACK AND ASK WHY DO WE
SEE RACIAL HEALTH DISPARITIES
IN THE FIRST PLACE. WELL WE
COULD SPEND THE REST OF THE DAY
UNPACKING THIS BUT IT ALL
REALLY BOILS DOWN TO RACISM.
DUE TO HISTORIC AND ONGOING
RACIST POLICIES AND PRACTICES
THAT PART CHILDREN FAMILIES AND
INDIVIDUALS FROM EQUAL ACCESS
TO HEALTH CARE EMPLOYMENT
HOUSING EDUCATION AND OTHER
OPPORTUNITIES TO THRIVE.
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR HAVE
UNDERLYING HEALTH CONDITIONS
THAT MAKE THEM MORE VULNERABLE
TO HEALTH THREATS LIKE COVERT
NINETEEN. THERE IS A LOT OF
RESEARCH THAT DOCUMENTS HOW
RACISM PERSISTS IN VARIOUS
INSTITUTIONS AND HOW THAT
NEGATIVELY IMPACTS HEALTH BUT
LET ME JUST HIGHLIGHT ONE
CONCRETE EXAMPLE. OUR
ENVIRONMENT EVERYONE DESERVES
TO LIVE IN A HEALTHY
ENVIRONMENT BUT THE REALITY IS
THAT COMMUNITIES OF COLOR
PARTICULARLY BLACK AND LATIN
NEXT CALIFORNIANS ARE MORE
LIKELY TO LIVE IN NEIGHBORHOODS
WITH POOR AIR QUALITY. AND IN
CLOSER PROXIMITY TO HAZARD IS
WASTE SITES THAN WHITE
CALIFORNIANS. ALSO BLACK LATIN
NEXT AND ASIAN CALIFORNIANS ARE
ON AVERAGE EXPOSED TO MORE
POLLUTION FROM VEHICLES LIKE
CARS TRUCKS AND BUSES AS THEN
WHITE CALIFORNIANS. AND THIS IS
NOT ACCIDENTAL ENVIRONMENTAL
FACTORS ARE DEEPLY ROOTED IN
RACIST POLICIES AND ACTIONS
SUCH AS GOVERNMENT SUPPORTED
HOUSING DISCRIMINATION
REDLINING SEGREGATION UNEQUAL
DISTRIBUTION OF POWER AND
DISINVESTMENT FROM COMMUNITIES.
HARMFUL CHEMICALS AND POLLUTION
IN THE ENVIRONMENT IRRITATE THE
LUNGS AND CONTRIBUTE TO
RESPIRATORY AND CARDIOVASCULAR
HEALTH PROBLEMS INCLUDING
ASTHMA A LUNG CANCER AND HEART
DISEASE. THESE TOXIC UNHEALTHY
CONDITIONS ARE HARMFUL TO
HEALTH AND IT ALSO INCREASES
THE RISK OF SEVERE ILLNESS FROM
COVERT NINETEEN. A RECENT STUDY
IN FACT FOUND AN ASSOCIATION
BETWEEN LONG TERM EXPOSURE TO
AIR POLLUTION AND A COUNTY'S
COVERT NINETEEN MORTALITY RATE.
SO WHEN I TALK ABOUT THESE
CONDITIONS IN WHICH WE LIVE
LEARN WORK PLAY AN AGE I'M
REFERRING TO THE SOCIAL
DETERMINANTS OF HEALTH WHICH
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ADAM BLATT
MENTIONED EARLIER. RESEARCH
SHOWS THAT THE SOCIAL
DETERMINANTS OF HEALTH
SIGNIFICANTLY IMPACT HEALTH AND
ACTUALLY HAS A MUCH GREATER
IMPACT ON HEALTH OUTCOMES THAN
MEDICAL CARE. IN OTHER WORDS
BECAUSE OF ONGOING AND HISTORIC
RACISM AND DISCRIMINATION THE
CONTEXT OF A COMMUNITY OR WHERE
A PERSON LIVES MATTERS. FOR
THEIR OVERALL HEALTH AND WELL
BEING SO IT'S ALL IN HERE BUT
YOU CAN FIND MORE OF OUR WORK
INCLUDING OUR UPCOMING REPORT
ON THIS TOPIC ON OUR WEBSITE
CAL BUDGET CENTER DOT ORG.
THANK YOU AGAIN FOR INVITING US
TO PARTICIPATE IN THIS
IMPORTANT CHANNEL AND I LOOK
FORWARD TO ANY QUESTIONS. GIVE
THANK YOU NEXT WE HAVE DOCTOR
MAHDI LANDED THAT THREE KNOW
THAT YOUNG. A PUBLIC HEALTH
PROFESSOR UC MERCED. GOOD
AFTERNOON. AS CHAIR WOMEN
GONZALEZ MEMBERS OF THE SELECT
COMMITTEE AND MY FELLOW
PANELISTS. MY GRANDMOTHER LISA
WAS BORN INTO THE VEST
NICARAGUA IN NINETEEN EIGHTEEN
THE YEAR OF THE SPANISH FLU.
I'M LAST YEAR AT THE AGE OF A
HUNDRED INTO SHE CONTRACTED
CODE NINETEEN. FORTUNATELY SHE
SURVIVED BUT IN THE PROCESS OF
CARING FOR HER. EACH OF THE
WOMEN IN MY FAMILY ALSO
CONTRACTED COULD NINETEEN. SO
AS A MEMBER OF. CALIFORNIA'S
LATINO POPULATION THIS HEARING
TODAY IS DEEPLY PERSONAL FOR ME
AND I THINK YOUR PREP LIFTING
THE VOICES OF LATINOS ACROSS
THE STATE. AS AN IMMIGRANT
HEALTH RESEARCHER THE WELL
BEING OF LATINO IMMIGRANTS HAS
BECOME INTEGRAL TO MY WORK OVER
THE LAST YEAR. MY PRIMARY
MESSAGE TODAY IS THAT. NOT ONLY
HAS CODE NINETEEN PANDEMIC
EXACERBATED HEALTH INEQUITIES
FOR LET YOU KNOW AS A WHOLE.
BUT IT HAS DEEP IN THE
INEQUITIES IN HEALTH THAT EXIST
WITHIN OUR STATE'S DIVERSE
LATINO POPULATION BASED ON
CITIZENSHIP AND LEGAL STATUS.
AMONG CALIFORNIA'S THAT THE
ENOUGH ABOUT 20% LACK THE
PROTECTIONS OF CITIZENSHIP.
PRIOR TO THE PANDEMIC ABOUT 50%
OF THESE NONCITIZEN LEFT IN US
THIS INCLUDES UNDOCUMENTED
WOMEN WOMEN WITH DACA TPS AND
EVEN GREEN HEARTS LACKED HEALTH
INSURANCE. STUDIES IN
CALIFORNIA AND ACROSS THE US
HAVE ALSO SHOWN THAT NONCITIZEN
LATINOS ARE LESS LIKELY TO HAVE
A REGULAR SOURCE OF HEALTH CARE
EVEN IF THEY HAVE INSURANCE.
WHEN THE CALL NINETEEN PANDEMIC
STARTED I INITIATED THE YOU
MUST STUDY A STUDY OF KOBE
NINETEEN AND LET YOU KNOW
FAMILIES AND IMMIGRANT
CALIFORNIA TRIDENTINE FIND HOW
THE PANDEMIC. WAS AFFECTING THE
WELL BEING OF LATINO IMMIGRANT
FAMILIES AND STOP OR STATES
HARDEST HIT COMMUNITIES. I HAVE
SHARED YOUR RESEARCH BRIEF
WHICH ASSEMBLY MEMBER ADAM
WITHOUT ALREADY REFERRED TO AND
THANK YOU FOR READING THAT
QUOTE FROM ONE OF THE WOMEN IN
TULARE COUNTY WE INTERVIEWED.
MY TEAM CONDUCTED IN DEPTH
INTERVIEWS WITH TWENTY ONE
IMMIGRANT LATINOS IN MERCED.
FRESNO TULARE AND IMPERIAL
COUNTIES. THE STUDY RESPONDENTS
WERE INDIVIDUALS WHO ALREADY
FACE SIGNIFICANT COST LANGUAGE
AND ELIGIBILITY BARRIERS TO
HELP. WE COMPLEMENTED THESE
INTERVIEWS WITH SEVENTEEN
INTERVIEWS WITH IMMIGRANT
SERVING ORGANIZATIONS WHO ARE
ALREADY SERVING AS THE SAFETY
NET FOR THIS POPULATION TODAY I
WANT TO HIGHLIGHT FOR YOU THREE
FINDINGS THAT RAISED
SIGNIFICANT CONCERNS. ABOUT THE
LONG TERM WELL BEING OF THAT
THE- FIRST I'D LIKE TO REPORT
OUR FINDINGS REGARDING MENTAL
HEALTH. RESPONDENTS ACROSS
COUNTIES DESCRIBED HEIGHTENED
ANXIETY DEPRESSION SLEEP
PROBLEMS AND OTHERSIGNS THE
MOTION ALL AND MENTAL DISTRESS.
IS MENTAL HEALTH CHALLENGES
REALLY EMERGED AT THE
INTERSECTION OF THE EXCLUSION
THAT LATINOS ALREADY FACE AS
IMMIGRANTS AND WITH THE NEW
STRAINS OF THE PANDEMIC SO
MOTHERS MANY OF WHOM HAD TO
LEAVE WHO HAD TO LEAVE THE
WORKFORCE BASE STRESSED OVER
MODES SCHOOLING. AND OFTEN
DESCRIBED THEIR OWN SPOUSES AND
CHILDREN DETERIORATING MENTAL
HEALTH. FAMILIES FACE FINANCIAL.
AND RESULTING STRESS AS THEY
STRUGGLE TO MEET BASIC NEEDS.
NUMEROUS RESPONDED SHARED A
SENSE OF DISCRIMINATION FROM
BEING EXCLUDED FROM POLICIES
SUCH AS THE FEDERAL STIMULUS
WERE ALSO A SOURCE OF STRESS
FOR THEM AND OF COURSE
RESPONDENTS HAD FEW ACCESS TO
MENTAL HEALTH RESOURCES AND THE
FEW THAT DID. FOUND THAT THE
REMOTE MOVED TO REMOTE ONLINE
MENTAL HEALTH TREATMENT WAS A
SIGNIFICANT BARRIER. SECOND OUR
REPORT OUR FINDINGS AROUND FOOD
AND SECURITY MOST RESPOND
RESPOND RESPOND AS REPORTED
INCREASED USE OF EMERGENCY FOOD
RESOURCES SUCH AS FOOD BANKS
AND PANTRIES. WITH SCHOOLS
CLOSED FAMILIES YOU HAD TO FEED
CHILDREN THROUGHOUT THE DAY AND
HAD LIMITED ACCESS TO TAKE AWAY
SCHOOL MEALS LOST INCOME AND
VOLATILE FOOD PRICES MADE FOOD
PURCHASES VERY DIFFICULT. AND
DESPITE CONNECTING WITH CHARITY
FEED RESOURCES RESPONDENTS
OFTEN HAD TO DEDICATE HOURS TO
LINING UP FOR FOOD DONATIONS.
SOMETIMES ONLY TO BE TURNED
AWAY WHEN FOOD BOXES RIGHT NOW.
RESPONDENTS ALSO REPORTED
CONCERN ABOUT THE NUTRITIONAL
VALUE OF PRESERVED FOODS OFTEN
PROVIDED BY FOOD BANKS. FINALLY
I WANT TO REPORT ON THE IMPACT
OF THE FEDERAL PUBLIC CHARGE
ROLE AND THE IMPACT IT'S HAD TO
LET YOU KNOW IMMIGRANTS DURING
THE COULD NINETEEN CONDEMNED.
IN OUR INTERVIEWS WITH SERVICE
PROVIDERS. RESPONDENTS REPORTED
CONCERNS THAT LEAVE THE LEGAL
IMPLICATIONS OF USING PUBLIC
BENEFITS. AND THE SOCIAL STIGMA
AROUND IMMIGRANTS USE THE
PUBLIC BENEFITS. HAD
EXACERBATED LET THE MOST
FAMILIES BARRIERS TO CRITICAL
HEALTH SOCIAL SERVICE AND
ECONOMIC RESOURCES. ALTHOUGH
THIS IS A FEDERAL POLICY AND
IT'S LIKELY TO CHANGE UNDER NEW
PRESIDENT. THERE ARE WHAT ARE
LIKELY GOING TO BE LASTING
BARRIERS TO SERVICES THAT ARE
PROVIDED BY STATE LOCAL AND
EVEN PRIVATE INSTITUTIONS. WE
HEARD THAT PUBLIC CHARGES
COMPLEXITIES AND ITS
INTERSECTIONS WITH ELIGIBILITY
REQUIREMENTS FOR MANY STATE
PROGRAMS HAS INCREASED THE
BURDEN ON IMMIGRANTS SERVICE
PROVIDERS AS THEY STRUGGLE TO
MEET THEIR CLIENTS NEEDS. AND
HAD REDUCE DISTRUST AMONG
IMMIGRANT COMMUNITY MEMBERS.
WELL THE HELP OUTLOOK FOR
LATINAS AT THIS MOMENT IS
DISCOURAGING I WILL END MY
REMARKS BY HIGHLIGHTING THE
CRITICAL ROLE OF OUR STATE'S
POLICIES. THAT THEY'VE ALREADY
PLAYED REALLY IN ADDRESSING
HEALTH INEQUITIES- BECAUSE OF
GREAT WORK BECAUSE OF FROM
POLICY MAKERS LIKE YOU
CALIFORNIA NATIONALLY IT'S BEEN
AT THE FOREFRONT. OF ENACTING
PUBLIC POLICIES THAT CREATE
SOCIAL AND ECONOMIC PROTECTIONS
FOR ITS IMMIGRANT RESIDENTS. I
STUDY A STATE LEVEL IMMIGRANT
POLICY EXAMINED THE
RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN POLICIES
THAT EXTEND ELIGIBILITY RIGHTS
AND OTHER PROTECTIONS TO
NONCITIZENS AND INSURANCE
HEALTH INSURANCE RATES. I'VE
SHARED A FACT SHEET THAT
SUMMARIZES THE STUDY'S KEY
FINDINGS. AND IN THIS STUDY I
SCORED ALL FIFTY STATES BASED
ON THE ENACTMENT OF TEN
DIFFERENT POLICIES THAT EXPENSE
EXTENT RIGHTS AND ELIGIBILITY
TO NON CITIZENS. STATES LIKE
CALIFORNIA SCORED VERY HIGH FOR
HAVING POLICIES SUCH AS
EXTENSION OF MEDIC HOW TO
UNDOCUMENTED CHILDREN AND
PREGNANT WOMEN. I'M STANDING
DRIVER'S LICENSES TO
UNDOCUMENTED IMMIGRANTS.
EXTENDING WORKER PROTECTIONS TO
IMMIGRANTS DOMINANT SECTORS AND
LIMITING COLLABORATION WITH
ICE. I LINK THESE STATE SCORES
WITH INDIVIDUAL INSURANCE DATA
FROM THE AMERICAN COMMUNITY
SURVEY. AND CONDUCTED ANALYSES
SHOWED THAT IN STATES LIKE
CALIFORNIA THAT HE DID NOT GIVE
SIGNIFICANT INCLUSIVE POLICIES
THERE WERE HIGHER RATES OF
HEALTH INSURANCE AMONGST NON
CITIZEN LEVINE ALSO THEN AND
LESS WELCOMING STATE. THIS
REALLY POINTS TO THE IMPORTANCE
OF PUBLIC POLICY INTERVENTIONS
ACROSS SECTORS NOT JUST IN
HEALTH POLICY BUT AS MY FELLOW
PANELISTS JUST MENTION ACROSS
DIFFERENT AREAS OF THE SOCIAL
DETERMINANTS OF HEALTH. THESE
POLICIES CAN MAKE A DIFFERENCE
IN. DRESSING INEQUITIES IN WELL
BEING BETWEEN US CITIZEN LEVINE
AS AN IMMIGRANT UNITS. MOVING
FORWARD ACCESS TO MENTAL HEALTH
CARE AND NUTRITION RESOURCES
REGARDLESS OF LEGAL STATUS WILL
BE CRITICAL TO HELP WITH THAT
THE KNOWS. WHETHER THIS
PANDEMIC IN THE LONGER TERM
THERE IS WORK TO BE DONE TO
BREAK DOWN BOTH LEGAL AND
SOCIAL BARRIERS TO LATINO
IMMIGRANTS RIGHT TO HELP. THANK
YOU AND I LOOK FORWARD TO YOUR
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU THAT WAS
VERY THOROUGH- WE ARE NOW GOING
TO HEAR FROM ROSA. MARIA AND
REGISTERED NURSE AT UC SAN
FRANCISCO IN CHIEF NURSE
REPRESENTATIVE WITH CALIFORNIA
NURSES ASSOCIATION. GROSSA.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS AND FELLOW PANELISTS.
MY NAME IS ROSS I'VE YET WELL I
AM A REGISTERED NURSE WITH THE
CALIFORNIA. NURSES ASSOCIATION
AND ITS CHIEF NURSE RIGHT FOR
UCSF MISSION BAY. IDENTIFY AS
AN INDIGENOUS MICHAEL G. LET
YOU KNOW WOMAN BORN TO
IMMIGRANT PARENTS IT'S FROM
SHEILA. I APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK WITH YOU
AND SHARE HOW THE CODEPENDENT
MAKE HAS DISPROPORTIONATELY
IMPACT. ACTED IN PATIENTS ON
THE FIRST. AND ALSO THE LAST
UNITY AS A WHOLE OF COURSE WE
ALL FIRST LETTER TO THE CODEPEN
DEDICATE IN DECEMBER OF TWENTY
EIGHTEEN AND WATCHED IN HORROR
AS IT'S MADE ITS WAY WORLDWIDE.
I JANUARY TWENTY TWENTY MY
COLLEAGUES AND I WITH THE
BACKING OF CNA ARE NURSES
UNION. WE'RE STARTING TO ASK
SOME VERY IMPORTANT QUESTIONS.
HOW PREPARED ARE WE AS A
HOSPITAL. WHAT SHOULD WE BE
DOING TO MITIGATE THIS
IMPENDING PANDEMIC. AS A
HEALTHCARE COMMUNITY WE HAVE
ALWAYS KNOWN THE POTENTIAL FOR
ANOTHER MASSIVE PANDEMIC TO
OCCUR. WE HAD JUST A BIRDIE
BOLA AND FOUGHT HARD TO MAKE
SURE HOSPITALS WERE PREPARED
FOR THAT VIRUS. WE KNOW WAS
NURSES WE CAN BE CALLED INTO
BATTLE AGAINST MASS DISASTERS
VIRUSES MASS CASUALTIES AND
BEING IN CALIFORNIA WITH THE
POTENTIAL FOR EARTHQUAKES. IT
WAS JUST SOMETHING WE
UNDERSTOOD IT'S JUST A MATTER
OF TIME. WHAT TO SAY THAT WE
ARE MENTALLY PREPARED FOR COLD
IT AND HOW DEVASTATING IT WOULD
BECOME. WOULD BE A LIE. WE KNEW
THAT THE MOST VULNERABLE
POPULATIONS WOULD BE THOSE
ALREADY DISADVANTAGED IN
SOCIETY. IT WOULD BE THE BLACK
INDIGENOUS AND LATIN NEXT
COMMUNITY. YOU ONLY HAVE TO
LOOK AT HOW HISTORY AND SOCIAL
DETERMINANTS. ALREADY
PREDESTINED THIS AUTUMN. THERE
ARE A FEW THINGS THAT ME AND MY
COLLEAGUES WERE NOT PREPARED
FOR. INCLUDING THE COMPLETE
INCOMPETENCE OF THE FORMER
WHITE HOUSE ADMINISTRATION THE
WEAKENING OF THE CDC. AND THE
INTERACTIVE OFFICE OF CAL OSHA
AND THE UNWILLINGNESS OF
HOSPITALS TO PURSUE THE
PRECAUTIONARY PRINCIPLE. TO BE
SUCCINCT. THE PRECAUTIONARY
PRINCIPLE IS AN APPROACH TO
RISK MANAGEMENT THAT ENSURES
THAT WHEN YOU DON'T KNOW WHAT
YOU'RE DEALING WITH YOU GO
ABOVE AND BEYOND TO PROTECT THE
SAFETY OF THOSE INVOLVED DO AS
MUCH AS YOU CAN NOT THE LEAST
YOU CAN GET AWAY WITH. MY
COLLEAGUE CNA AND I'D HAVE
INSISTED THAT HOSPITALS APPLY
THIS PRINCIPLE. SORRY TO THE
CODEPENDENT ACT WHICH INCLUDES
A DEMAND FROM ALL WORKPLACES.
THE HIGHEST STANDARDS OF
PERSONAL PROTECTIVE EQUIPMENT
TRAINING AND HANDS ON
ADDITIONAL STAFFING TO PROTECT
PUBLIC HEALTH AND SAFETY. TO
THE DETRIMENT OF MANY OF OUR
COLLEAGUES INCLUDING THE MOST
SMALLER POPULATIONS THAT I
MENTIONED THE HOSPITAL'S FAILED
TO APPLY THE PRECAUTIONARY
PRINCIPLE. AS A CONSEQUENCE.
ONCE THE PARK COMMUNITY WERE
LEFT BEHIND BECAUSE BLACK AND
BROWN WORKERS TEND TO HAVE LESS
JOB PROTECTIONS YOUR JOB SUFFER
FROM JOB IN HOUSING AND
SECURITY HAVE LITTLE OR NO
HEALTH CARE COVERAGE AND LITTLE
TO NO SICK TIME. WORKING IN
MINIMUM WAGE JOB TO FEED YOUR
FAMILY AND YOURSELF PAY BILLS.
AND RENT LEAVE LITTLE TO COVER
HEALTH CARE COSTS. THIS WAS
EVIDENT PRIOR TO THE PANDEMIC
IN WAS EXACERBATED DURING COLD
IT. PRIOR TO THE PANDEMIC WE IN
HEALTHCARE HAVE KNOWN FOR A
LONG TIME THAT THERE'S A NEED
TO ADDRESS EQUITABLE CARE. AS A
NURSE OF TEN YEARS WORKING WITH
CHRONICALLY ILL PATIENTS I SEE
THE STRAIN ON FAMILY IS AS THEY
CARE FOR LOVED ONES. BATTLING
CHRONIC HEALTH CONDITIONS OR
DISEASE. I HAVE SEEN THE
DESPERATION OF FAMILIES THAT
STRUGGLE FINANCIALLY TO CARE
FOR THEIR LOVED ONES. TOO OFTEN
PAY FOR MEDICATIONS TO PAY FOR
TRANSPORTATION TO AND FROM
APPOINTMENTS. I KNOW THAT
PATIENTS WILL OFTEN WAIT UNTIL
THE PAIN IS UNBEARABLE TO
FINALLY COME INTO THE HOSPITAL.
WE NEED TO WORK AND PAYING FOR
A HSPITAL VISIT MEANS THERE IS
LESS MONEY FOR FOOD OR SOME
OTHER NECESSITY OR ITS TIME OFF
WORK THAT THEY CAN'T AFFORD.
THESE ISSUES ARE EXACERBATED
DURING COLD IT AS PEOPLE ARE
LAID OFF THEY HAVE LOST HOUSING
AND I'VE GOTTEN SICK. CARING
FOR MULTIPLE FAMILY MEMBERS IT
IS THE SAME STORY THAT CYNTHIA
LOPEZ SHARED EARLIER. HEALTH
CARE SHOULD NOT BE DETERMINED
BY SOCIAL ECONOMIC STATUS BUT
IN THE U. S. IT IS. COLD IT HAS
MADE THAT VERY EVIDENT. ACCESS
TO TESTING COVETED EDUCATION
AND EVEN HOUSING AND FOOD ARE
ALL INTEGRAL TO THE MITIGATION
OF THE VIRUS. WE SAW THIS LOW
OR NONEXISTENT ROLLOUT OF
TESTING CENTERS IN VULNERABLE
AREAS. IN SAN RAFAEL I ROLLINS
HERE TO SWAPPING SITE IN A
PREDOMINATELY LATIN EXPERIENCE.
WHAT I SAW WERE A LARGE NUMBER
OF COMMUNITY MEMBERS TESTING
POSITIVE. BUT WITH NO SUPPORT
FINANCIALLY THEY WOULD RETURN
TO WORK OR NOT ISOLATE DUE TO
LACK OF SUPPORT FROM THE CITY.
WHAT THE MOTHERS WERE ALSO NOW
HAVING TO CONTEND WITH HOME
SCHOOLING ANOTHER ADDED
RESPONSIBILITY TO ALREADY FULL
PLATES. HOW DOES A FAMILY
ISOLATE NOT WORKING FEED
THEMSELVES WITHOUT FINANCIAL
SUPPORT OR FOOD DELIVERY
SERVICES THIS IS NEAR
IMPOSSIBLE. THE WORLD WILL
POPULATION ISN'T JUST OUTSIDE
THE HOSPITAL WE ARE ALSO THE
STAFF IN THE HOSPITAL THE
SUPPORT STAFF FOUND ON EVERY
UNIT. AND THE NURSES WHO CARE
FOR OUR COMMUNITY. THE SAME
PROTECTIONS THAT ARE NEEDED FOR
THE COMMUNITY ARE ALSO NEEDED
FOR THE- WORKERS ARCING
LEADERSHIP TEAM AND I AT UCSF
ASKED FOR WEEKLY TESTING OF ALL
STAFF TIMELY CONTACT TRACING
WOULD PROBABLY BE TO PROTECT
OURSELVES AND OUR PATIENTS I
QUOTED STAFF TO MEET OUR
ARGUMENTS PERSONAL I MAKE NOISE
HOWEVER I COULD. WE MAKE NOISE.
WE. MY UNION BROTHERS AND
SISTERS ACROSS THE UC SYSTEM
MAKE NOISE TO KEEP THE PRESSURE
UP BUT WE'RE STILL RE USING OUR
AND NINETY FIVES REUSING ARE
SINGLE USE PP WE ARE STILL
SHORT STAFFED AND ARE STILL
RAISING OUR CONCERNS WE SEE TOO
OFTEN IN MONEY PROFITS OVER
PATIENT CARE HOW DO WE PROVIDE
EQUITABLE CARE WHEN THE
HOSPITAL INDUSTRY CREATES
BARRIERS OR TIES OUR HANDS
BEHIND OUR BACK. OUT SIDE OF
THE COMMUNITY. THE LOT NEXT
COMMUNITY WAS NOT RECEIVED.
TIMELY ACCURATE OR CULTURALLY
APPROPRIATE RESOURCES OR
INFORMATION. THIS HAS LED TO AN
EFFECTIVE OUTREACH. FUELED BY
RACIST RHETORIC FROM THE FORMER
ADMINISTRATION. THERE HAS BEEN
AN INFORMATION VACUUM THAT HAS
LED TO THE LACK OF PUBLIC
HEALTH DATA. TO CAPTURE THE
IMPACT OF COATED ON WHAT NEXT
UNITIES. THIS WAS EVIDENT BY
THE FAILURE OF THE CDC. THE
WORLD HEALTH ORGANIZATION
STATES QUOTE. HE CALLED
DISTRIBUTION OF HEALTH DAMAGING
EXPERIENCES IS NOT IN ANY SENSE
AND NATURAL PHENOMENON WHAT IS
THE RESULT OF TOXICOLOGY OF
COURSE SOCIAL POLICIES UNFAIR
ECONOMIC ARRANGEMENTS AND BAD
POLITICS SOCIAL DETERMINANTS
CAN INCLUDE UNEMPLOYMENT INCOME
EDUCATION WORKING CONDITIONS
FOOD AND SECURITY HOUSING
SOCIAL INCLUSION DISCRIMINATION
STRUCTURAL CONFLICT ACCESS TO
AFFORDABLE HEALTH SERVICES AND
EARLY CHILDHOOD DEVELOPMENT.
THE BLACK AND BROWN COMMUNITIES
SUFFER FROM HIGHER RATES OF
OBESITY HIGH BLOOD PRESSURE
LIVER DISEASE DIABETES
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH DISPARITIES
HIGHER RATES OF BREAST CANCER
TO WOMAN INFECTION CAN
EXACERBATE THESE CONDITIONS
LEADING TO HIGHER INFECTION AND
DEATH RATES. MORTALITY RATE
TRANSCODED ARE THREE TO FIVE
TIMES HIGHER THAN OUR WHITE
COUNTERPARTS. WHEN WE TALK
ABOUT THE LET NEXT COMMUNITY MY
COMMUNITY WE MUST TAKE INTO
ACCOUNT THAT MY COMMUNITY IS
MADE UP OF THE ESSENTIAL
WORKERS OF CALIFORNIA WITH JOBS
IN AGRICULTURE RETAIL
RESTAURANT INDUSTRY LABOR
CONSTRUCTION AND HEALTH CARE.
WE'D A LOT THE NASS ARE THE
BACKBONE OF CALIFORNIA. BUT WE
ARE OFTEN EXPLOITED AS THE EVER
READY BUT EASILY FIRED OFTEN
NON UNIONIZED WORKFORCE WITH
WILL. LITTLE OR NO HEALTH CARE
COVERAGE SOCIAL ECONOMIC
VULNERABILITY DUE TO OVER
REPRESENTATION OF THE LOT NEXT
COMMUNITY AND LOW WAGE LABOR
MARKET. IS A DIRECT CORRELATION
TO POOR HEALTH OUTCOMES SO YOU
ASK HOW DO WE TACKLE THESE
ISSUES HOW DO WE MOVE TOWARDS
EQUITY AND HEALTH CARE AND
SOCIETY. WE MUST WORK TO
COORDINATE OUTREACH EFFORTS TO
MARGINALIZE COMMUNITIES TO
INCREASE ACCESS TO ST
CULTURALLY APPROPRIATE PUBLIC
EDUCATION CAMPAIGNS AND
SERVICES. WE MUST HAVE
CONSISTENT CULTURALLY
APPROPRIATE PUBLIC HEALTH
CAMPAIGNS OF INFORMATIONAL
MATERIALS THAT ARE INCLUSIVE OF
THE LOT NEXT COMMUNITY ANDY
SYMPTOMS TESTING SITES
RESOURCES VACCINE INFORMATION.
WE MUST LEVERAGE TRUSTED
COMMUNITY LEADERS BUILT ON THAT
TRUST THAT ALREADY EXIST WITH
THAT MANY COMMUNITY PROGRAMS.
ONE OF THE BARRIERS TO TESTING
IS THE THREAT OF IMMIGRATION
PRESENCE THAT'S HAS CONTINUED
CONTINUED THROUGHOUT THE
PANDEMIC. WE MUST ADVOCATE FOR
BROADER SOCIETAL CHANGES. TO
ADVANCE HEALTH EQUITY FOR ALL
ALL MARGINALIZED COMMUNITIES.
WE MUST. WE MUST I'M SORRY WE
MUST INVEST IN EQUITY IN ALL
POPULATIONS BY HAVING SYSTEM.
DIMS IN X. EQUAL ACCESS TO
HEALTH CARE OR SINGLE PAYER
INSURANCE LIVABLE WORKING WAGE
IS CREATION OF UNIONS
INVESTMENT IN COMMUNITY
PROGRAMS HEALTH CARE
INITIATIVES IN ALL ASPECTS OF
RACIAL AND SOCIAL JUSTICE THAT
IS HOW WE START TO BUILD A
HEALTHIER FUTURE. NO ONE SHOULD
HAVE TO MAKE THE CHOICE OF
HEALTHCARE OVER HOUSING OR
BILLS IT IS A TRAVESTY AND A
FAILURE OF THIS NATION. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. I'M WE'RE NOW
GOING TO HEAR FROM FOURTEEN
THAT OR NOT IS A FROM A TOYOTA
WHO CAN SHARE HER EXPERIENCES
WITH US AND- SHE'S GOING TO.
HEARD TESTIMONIES CAN BE
TRANSLATED BY ASHLEY. FORTY
NINE. SEE WE WENT AS BAD AS
THEY WERE WHEN I STARTED THIS I
THOUGHT THOSE. YEAH IT'S BETTER
KEY ELEMENT OF THAT A CESS FAST
YO WELCOME PARTY GET THE WITH
GOAL THE CUSTOMERS MATHIS.
THAT'S WHAT THE REST BY I'VE
GONE BACK. OKAY MADE UP BE ABLE
TO THREE THAT A YES AND CAN.
FROM WHICH I HAVE MY THAT A.
GOOD AFTERNOON COMMITTEE. GOOD
AFTERNOON TO EVERYBODY MY NAME
IS FOURTEEN THAT MANDATE I AM
VERY GRATEFUL TO HAVE THIS
SPACE TO ADDRESS YOU I WOULD
LIKE TO SHARE WITH ALL OF YOU
THAT I DID HAVE CALLED IT A FEW
MONTHS AGO- I DO HAVE TO TELL
YOU THAT I DID SPEND THIRTY
DAYS SICK WITH IT IT WAS A
TREMENDOUS FIGHT. THAT I WILL
NEVER FORGET. I WOKE UP WITH.
SPEAKING HIM YET STYLE AT THE
END AND RESPECTFUL AFTER. THIS
I FEEL I MEAN. FROM ON BAD
PEOPLE VIA AND SEE YOU. THEN
YOU DENTAL ME LESS HAS TAPPED
IN THE HE IS QUICK THEN THERE
CALL YOU DIEGO WATCH YOU HIM
THE. BUT THAT. SENT THE TO ME.
I DON'T KNOW I DON'T BASS AS HE
YOU EVEN SAID A SENIOR. THIS
LISTING MY THE FEAR LATE IN ARC.
IT WAS A CHALLENGE FOR TO BE
ABLE TO RAISE MY VOICE TO BREAK
SILENCE I WAS. AFRAID OF BEING
RICH BE IT HAD COLD IT WHEN YOU
HAVE CO YOU FEEL LIKE YOU'VE
COME A CRIME IT FEELS LIKE A
ST. SO THERE WAS A LOT OF FEAR
AND THERE IS A LOT OF FEAR
BECAUSE OF THIS. I MIGHT-
YESTERDAY MY- CHAFFEE C. GOD
I'LL TRY AND WE'LL SEE YOU ARE
NOT AN- WHAT. DID OUT BY FIVE
SEE THAT A LOOK WHY CAN'T AND
SYSTEM. ON THE GO THE WAY. I AM
VERY MEDICAL THE I CAST ST AND
THE THAT'S GOING TO START A
LIST FROM. IS MAYBE BECAUSE.
ASIDE FROM PHYSICAL AND THE
STRUGGLE I WAS. MADE- AWARE OF
THE LACK DIVERSE IN TWO OF WHEN
I HAD CALLED IT- I REALLY FELT
VERY ANXIOUS BECAUSE I CAN'T
UNDERSTAND WHAT THE MEDICAL
PROVIDERS WERE TELLING ME. WHAT
AN ADDED INCENTIVE SPEND WILL
CHECK WHAT WE GET IS A LOT GAS
TAX. MAYBE IT WAS BECAUSE
WEATHER DATA HACK BETTER STATUS
GLAD WORK UP SEEM AN THAT A
VIDEO. MY BOY CAST ELISE. I
DON'T WANT IF FUNDING PASSED
MEMBERS WHEN THAT GETS THE SAN
THE LINE BUT. WHAT AND THAT'LL
SPEAK BALLOT. NOT THAT OF
COURSE NEXT HE REALLY BUT A GET
YOUR. THAT IS THE ONLY SIZE
LEFT STUDY MENTAL. SO I WAS
ABLE TO OVERCOME THAT STE AND
WAS ABLE TO GO HOME RELEASED
THEY SAID I GO HOME IN THE CITY
HAVE TO BE IN QUARANTINE FOR
TWENTY DAY. SO I WILL ABLE TO
HOME ONCE I WAS HOME I FOUND
THAT I WAS GOING HUNGRY ACT
LEAVING THE HOUSE BECAUSE DID
NOT PROVIDE ME ANY RE. IN TERMS
OF BEING ABLE TO HELP ME WITH
MY MEALS. HEY WE IMPORT BANK
THEY ADDED. WHEN WE GET BACK I
SENT. THEY GET THAT ME I HIS
LAN PORT OF BREAKING THAT THE
ASK YOU KNOW THAT I'M LIKE SAY
SO HOW MANY MEN THIS YEAR OLD.
IT AND MANY MORE PRESS ME
THAT'S A ACT AT THE- LATER OKAY.
YEAH LIKE I SAY WENT THROUGH.
WHAT PROGRAM MASSACRES BLESS
YOU. ME SO IS VERY IN- THAT WE
UNDER THAT THE WHEN YOU GO HOME
AND YOU HAVE TO DO YOUR TWENTY
DAYS OF QUARANTINE YOU NEED TO
BE ABLE TO HAVING TO HAVE
ACCESS AS WELL TO YOUR MEALS
YOU NEED YOUR THREE MEALS A DAY
SO ONCE I AM ABLE TO GO HOME AT
THAT POINT I ALSO FIND THAT I
AM DEALING WITH DIFFERENT.
PROBLEMS AND OTHER
CIRCUMSTANCES. HOW TO ME THEY
CUENTA QUE LE LET THE SYSTEM.
IN AFFECT BATTLES. SO MORE AT
LESS PERCENT OF MYSELF BIG BASS.
WE WENT THAT WAY GASTON WAS
REVIEW THE LAST HOLDEN. WHAT IS
SAM. MORE FOR TO YES THAT MOST
IN THE OFFICE AT THE- ACCESS
ARTICLES. SO NOW WHEN I'M ABLE
RELY HOW LATINOS ARE BEING. I
DO REAL THAT ARC WE HAVE HIGH
POVERTY LEVELS AND SO I AM NOW
UNDERSTANDING ALL OF THE IMPACT
IT'S HAVING ON US IN TERMS OF
HAVING RESOURCES AVAILABLE. WE
ARE BACK IN THE SPECIALIST. BUT
WE THINK SOCIAL PROGRAMMING
THAT YOU MAKE THIS YEAR
SIZEABLE AVERAGE. YES IT WOULD
MEAN MOST COMMITTEE OUTSIDE THE
WHAT GOOD THE LIST AND IT WAS
GREAT WEAPON NEXT SO. HOW MANY
MEN DOES YOUNG YEAH WITHOUT
MANY. SO I AM REALIZING ALL
THOSE- IN OUR COMMUNITY ALL OF
US HAD CO FEET WE SHOULD HAVE
ALL. ASK TO HEALTHY NUTRITION
TO HEALTHY MEALS AT LEAST A
THREE MEALS A DAY. BECAUSE WE
SHOULD ALL HAVE THE RIGHT TO
HEALTH CARE. AND TO. TO BE ABLE
TO HAVE HEALTHY MEALS AS WELL.
YOU SEE THAT A LITTLE WHACK
ASSIST FAMILY FOR TENNESSEE
STATE MY- YES I LOW. MOST ABOUT
HAD IN MY BY YEAH THERE'S BASED
ON A LADY THE OLD. IT'S ALMOST.
MORE PEOPLE THAT I DON'T. YOU
CAN THAT YOUR GRANDMA SALAS
BATTER BY TUESDAY MY MANY. YUP
ONE WASN'T THE LOCAL ARE YOU.
IT'S ALSO IN. TO WONDER. THE
THERE'S A LACK OF LINK. DIVER
IN HEALTH. WE NEED BETTER SERVE.
LET ACCESS WE ARE MORE. KERR
AND SO WE CANNOT GO. TO GET
HEALTH CARE AND THEN FIND THE
OPPOSITE. WHAT DO YOU HAVE
THEIR STUFF AND THEY HALF COULD
NOT SCRAMBLES AND AT EVERY ITEM
SEE STATE MASSEY SIMILAR SPACE.
MY THINK AND LET'S HAVE A WAS
MONEY HIS STAND LOOK AT WHEN I
BELLOWED AT. NO MORE THAN ONE I
SAY DON'T I SEE BACK EVEN THEM
SAYS THOSE BROKE BY I WAS SAD.
DEMOCRATS SAID LAST PASSED.
SEVERAL SAID IT GO. ANOTHER
THING THAT I DURING DEPEND IS
THAT WE DON'T ALL HAVE THIS OF
TO ACT. THE IN THROUGH A
COMPUTER MAY TO GET TEN MAYBE
TO GO INTO THE SYSTEM AND HOW
OUR NEEDS TAKEN CARE OF WE
DON'T ALL HAVE COMPUTERS WE'RE
NOT ALL EQUALLY ABLE TO GET OUR
APPOINTMENTS IN THE HEALTH CARE
SYSTEMS OR EVEN TO GET OUR
TESTS DONE. WHAT IS HE TRAVELS
DAILY APPLE MONEY THAT COMENZó
HANDLES IT MASKELL FIANCE. BUT
AS WHEN ASKED BUT I LOOK I SEE
FIND AEROSPACE GIVES THEM ONE
SENATE GOT APPLE. WE THAT. SO I
DO FEEL THE WE NEED BETTER OUT
TO OUR COMMUNITIES WE NEED
THOSE TRUSTED MESSENGERS THAT
ARE ABLE TO BE IN THE
COMMUNITIES AND OFFER EDUCATION
OFFER INFORMATION ON
VACCINATIONS OFFER. INFORMATION
ON TESTING AS WELL. THE LADY AT
THE ANYTHING YELLOW JACKASS
ATTY AND I SINCE THE LAST DAYS
THE- LASTED BUT A WORLD THAT
SINGLE LIMIT AND WILL CHILDREN
THIS ASSEMBLY THE ONE INTO
GARCIA OF. YEAH THIS IS. THE
OLD LOOKING IF YOU GUYS JUMP
EVEN AND OF STYLE RIGHT INTO
YOU CAST YOUR- AND THOSE. AND
EXPENSIVE. RECALL ME BACK. I SO
P. IN OUR- THEY CAN SCARY WHEN
ASKED TO GO GET A TEN BECAUSE A
LOT OF QUESTIONS ARE BEING
ASKED OR THEY CAN THEMSELVES
FEEL SCARED TO ASK ANY
QUESTIONS OR THAT THEY'RE GOING
TO BE ASKED TO SHOW ID. IN OUR
COMMUNITY THERE ARE PEOPLE WHO
HAVE NO IDEA WHERE THEY CAN BE
SCARED TO FIND THEMSELVES IN
THAT KIND OF A SITUATION SO
THAT REPRESENTS ANOTHER
OBSTACLE. FOR OUR COMMUNITY.
LOCAL MENTAL SUITE CS IN THE
WONDER ABOUT VERIFYING I GUESS.
ACTS WHAT THE WHAT MASKS.
SKINNER SAID ELEMENT THAT'S
YOUNG AWARDS PROGRAM AS IT GOT.
IT THE SAME. ONE BUT WHAT I'M
ASKING SO. NOTICES THAT BUT I
RESPECT HIM MOST UNPRETTY
RELATE HE'LL- IN ESSENCE HE-
MOST A LAB. IS THOSE DIGAMOS
THAT HAND. FOR ALSO P. WHO THAT
DON'T FIND AT THE HAVE AN OPS
AND OF WHEN THEY ABLE TO ACT
OTHER OF PRO. FOR BY CAL AND
EMPLOYEE. AND OTHER PROGRAMS
THEY MIGHT NEED SO- THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT SHOULD ALSO BE
UNDERSTOOD IS NOT A PRIVILEGE
IT'S A NEED FOR OUR COMMUNITY
AND THEREFORE WE NEED TO
ADVOCATE FOR OUR COMMUNITY SO
THEY HAVE ACCESS. TO ALL OF
THIS. YEAH THE NAME OKAY THERE
WERE SEVERAL YEAH I JUST THIS
FUN HAS THE I MEAN THINK IT
BEGINNING ABLE JANET YOU KNOW
GO DAUGHTER. WHAT DO NOT THE
END USER WILL MAYBE BOOKS DAYS
MAN SKIN ENEMY. YEAH OF COURSE
HOW BE AND PROCESS THINK THIS
BEING OUT UNLESS I OF A MINUTE
YEAH. ONE THOUGH YEAH. THEY
NEED WE ARE SAT. YES I'M EFFORT
ADULT. I KNOW WE STILL HAVE
PEOPLE IN OUR- YOU KNOW
COMMUNITIES IN FAMILY LIKE EVEN
MY OWN FAMILY WE FEEL SCARED
WHEN IT'S TO GO TO THE BE PER
THEY WERE HAVE ANY. OR PER THEY
DON'T HAVE ANY DA THE CAN SHOW
I'M THEY'RE SCARED THAT THEY'RE
GOING TO HOME AND HAVE A BILL
WAITING FOR THEM BECAUSE OF NOT
HAVING INSURANCE SO BY THE TIME
THEY DO GET MEDICAL CARE IS IN
AN EMERGENCY ROOM WHICH IS. A
VERY LATE STAGE TO GET MEDICAL
CARES TO GET MEDICAL CARE AND
SO THEY ARE BEING IMPACTED.
YEAH AFTER A HAD CABS WAIT I'M
AM GONNA CASES SAY THE ALMOST
WASN'T ELSE I WAS THE NAME IN
MOST IN THAT. THE ONLY A PLUS
BECAUSE THE HOST IN THE PROPER.
IS A LIST LOCAL. YOU ALSO HELLO
ALMOST HAVE. LAWS MAKE IS
GETTING A MOST THAN ANY
BACKSEAT LET THERE BE BE IN
THAT. LEGAL RIGHT I BY WITH A
SUSPECT WEAPONS YES. MODOC
BALLAST. SH AND IT'S FROM THAT
UNDER THING THAT IS WHAT OUR CA
VERY MUCH OUT THERE IS WORRY
ABOUT THE LATE PAY OF OUR- YES
IS THOUGH A BIG ARE HAPPY BUT
WE'RE WE'RE NOW BE WITHIN HOW
ARE WE GOING PAY FOR THE THAT
WE'RE GOING END UP OWING HER WE
GOING TO PAY FOR OUR HOUSE AND
HOW WE GOING TO PAY FOR ALL
THOSE LATE BILLS THAT WE'VE NOT
BEEN ABLE TO PAY SO FAR SO THAT
IS ALSO OF A CONCERN. TO OUR
COMMUNITY. YOU KNOW SOMEONE WHO
THIS WAY TO FACE ALMOST AS
THAT'S ONE THEY LIKE BEING GET
THEIR NAME WAS NOT REALLY THAT
IS A YOU KNOW A LOT. IT IN MAIN
GO HE FEEDS. YOU SEE PEARL JAM
CONVEY BETTER AMP. WHERE IS
THAT IN MOST A MEDIATOR APPLE
THAT. A LETTER THAT HE SAYS HE
MOST. GAMERS THAT WE SAVE CHAT
AT. GET WHICH IN MOST HONEST
SEE THAT. YEP WELL YOU KNOW
THIS IS THAT IT'S GET THE NAME
YOU DOES THEIR MOST I HAD A
STATE GRAHAM YOU. IN WAYS THAT
SCHOOL THAT IS. THANK YOU FOR
THE SUPPORT TWENTY. SO LETTING
US WE ARE WOMEN'S AT THE NOTES
ARE STRONG AND WE ARE ABLE GO
ON EVEN DURING TO TIMES WE KNOW
HOW TO HAVE FAITH AND WE KNOW
HOW TO HAVE HOW TO HAVE HOPE
FOR OUR FAMILIES AND FOR OUR
COMMUNITIES BUT WE NEED OUR
VOICES TO BE LISTENED TO. SO
THAT TOGETHER WE CAN MOVE
FORWARD AND WE CAN MAKE CHANGES
IN OUR COMMUNITIES. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOURTEEN AND THAT WAS
ACTUALLY VERY THOROUGH OF WHITE
I THINK. WE'RE HEARING ON THE
GROUND AS WELL- IT I REALIZE
WERE BUMPING UP AGAINST TWO
O'CLOCK WE STILL HAVE ONE
PANELIST I HAD A REQUEST THAT
I'M GONNA- GRANT AND THAT'S
THAT THE CHAIRWOMAN OF OUR
LATINO CAUCUS WANTS TO SAY A
QUICK WORD SHE HAS A TWO
O'CLOCK. SO SHE SHOULD BE ON
THE WEB BACKS- SENATOR MONEY
LANDED AWESOME. HI THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GONZALEZ I JUST
I'M I'M SORRY TO. INTERRUPT
YOUR- YOUR FLOW HERE OF SUCH A
TREMENDOUS WOMAN I JUST WANTED
TO. LET EVERYBODY KNOW THAT
WE'RE VERY PROUD THAT- ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GONZALEZ IS LEADING
THIS. INITIATIVE AND I
ESPECIALLY LIKE THE WAY SHE
SAID AS WE GOT IDENTIFY. AND
QUANTIFY IN ORDER FOR US TO
RESOLVE AND ADDRESS THE ISSUES
FACING A LATINO WOMEN- AND IT'S
BECAUSE OF HER LEADERSHIP THAT
THE LATINO CAUCUSES. ALL IN TO
DO EVERYTHING THAT WE CAN
SUGGEST YOU MEMBER. YOUR ROLE.
IN COMING TODAY. THANK YOU ME-
IS IT REALLY ESSENTIAL TO
FINDING SOLUTIONS SO THANK YOU
ALL OF THE LISTENING TO
EVERYTHING FROM THE ECONOMIC
IMPACTS TO THE HEALTHCARE
IMPACTS AND- AND I COULD SEE
THAT THERE ARE HUNDREDS WHO ARE
HAVE PAID ATTENTION. TO USING-
PAYING ATTENTION TO THIS AND
INVOLVED IN THIS SO AGAIN THANK
YOU ALL VERY MUCH AND I HAVE
SOME FOLLOW UP QUESTIONS BUT
I'LL PASS THEM ON TO THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER- AFTER THE
PAST. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU SENATOR. AT WE'RE
GOING TO GO TO OUR LAST- I'VE
CERTAINLY NOT LEAST I
UNDERSTAND SOME PEOPLE WILL
NEED TO LEAVE BECAUSE THEY HAD
A PLACE TO CATCH BUT BUT WE
WILL CONTINUE AND TELL US ALL
THE WAY THROUGH FOR PEOPLE WHO-
HAVE QUESTIONS ARE LAST BUT NOT
LEAST. AS PANELIST IS DOCTOR
AQUINO. THE LATINO COALITION
FOR A HEALTHY CALIFORNIA'S
DEPUTY DIRECTOR DR KENA. THANK
YOU CHAIRWOMAN GONZALEZ AND HIS
TEAM TO MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. I AM DOCTOR SAYS THE
AQUINO DEPUTY DIRECTOR AT THE
LATINO COALITION FOR HEALTHY
CALIFORNIA. IT IS IMPORTANT TO
EMPHASIZE THAT LATINOS ARE AT
HIGHER RISK OF CONTRACTING AND
DYING TO PROVIDE NINETEEN. DUE
TO POOR OUTCOMES REFLECTED
ACROSS ALL SOCIAL DETERMINANTS
OF HEALTH. STRUCTURAL RACISM
AND ECONOMIC EXPLOITATION THAT
PERPETUATES INEQUITY ANTENA
PHOBIC SENTIMENTS THAT CONTINUE
TO DAMAGE TRUST AND SAFETY IN
OUR COMMUNITIES. IT IS OUR
RESPONSIBILITY TO ADDRESS
HEALTH INEQUITIES PLAGUING
MEDINA. IN DOING SO WE ARE
SIMULTANEOUSLY INVESTING IN THE
HEALTH AND WELL BEING OF
FAMILIES COMMUNITIES THE STATE
AND OUR ECONOMY. THE FIRST STEP
TOWARDS ADDRESSING HEALTH
INEQUITIES FOR LETTING US IS TO
ACKNOWLEDGE OUR DIGNITY AND
POWER. LATINOS ARE NOT JUST
LEADERS IN THE HOME BUT IN
THEIR COMMUNITIES JOBS AND
NETWORKS. WE PLAY MULTIPLE
ROLES TO NAME JUST A FEW HEALTH
NAVIGATORS CULTURAL BROKERS
INVESTORS FINANCIAL MANAGERS
AND EDUCATORS. THIS IS WHY IT
IS OUR DUTY TO EXPLORE MULTI
SECTORAL APPROACHES THAT WILL
SEEK SHORT TERM AND LONG TERM
SOLUTIONS. LEADS LOUISE ALL
WHILE PURSUING A CULTURE OF
HEALTH. SOLUTIONS INCLUDE WINE
ACHIEVE TRUE HEALTH FOR ALL.
YOU WILL THE SHORT AND LONG
TERM SOLUTION IS TO FULLY
ACHIEVE HEALTH FOR ALL. COVERT
NINETEEN EPIDEMIC THAT
DISPROPORTIONATELY AFFECTS LOW
INCOME WORKING AGE ADULTS AND
SENIORS SERVES AS KEY EVIDENCE
AS TO WHY IT IS TIME TO FULLY
EXPAND ACCESS TO FULL SCOPE
MEDI CAL FOR ALL. REGARDLESS OF
IMMIGRATION STATUS IT IS TIME
TO EXPAND ACCESS AND NOT JUST
TO SENIORS BUT ALSO TO WORKING
AGE ADULTS. THIS INVESTMENT
WILL NOT ONLY ALLEVIATE SOME OF
THE DIRE IMMEDIATE EFFECTS OF
COVERT NINETEEN BUT ALSO
PREVENT DISPARITIES FROM ANY
FUTURE PANDEMICS OR CLIMATE
CHANGE CRISES THAT MIGHT COME
OUR WAY. SECOND PROMOSI TJ
COVERT NINETEEN OUTREACH. FROM
PREVENTION EFFORTS TESTING
CONTACT TRACING TO VACCINE
DISTRIBUTION WE MUST ENSURE
THAT WE MEET COMMUNITY MEMBERS
WHERE THEY ARE. NAVIGATING
CURRENT SYSTEMS IS PROVING A
BARRIER TO EQUITABLE ACCESS WE
MUST BE CREATIVE AND TAP INTO
EXISTING COMMUNICATION AND
TRUST NETWORKS. SET UP
DISTRIBUTION IN KEY COMMUNITY
FRIENDLY CENTERS SUCH AS
SCHOOLS AND PLACES OF WORSHIP.
UTILIZE MOBILE CLINICS TO REACH
THOSE WITHOUT TRANSPORTATION.
AND HIGHER PROMOTE THOUGHT US
TO CARRY OUT THE MESSAGE BY
STRATEGICALLY CONNECTING WITH
THE COMMUNITY WE WOULD ENSURE
THAT RESOURCES ARE EFFECTIVELY
AND EFFICIENTLY REACHING THOSE
MOST DISPROPORTIONATELY
AFFECTED. THIRD INCREASE ACCESS
TO THE EXISTING SAFETY NET. WE
MUST INCREASE ACCESS FOR
UNDOCUMENTED COMMUNITY MEMBERS
TO SAFETY NET OPTIONS SUCH AS
CALFRESH AND CAL WORKS.
INCREASING ACCESS TO OUR
NUTRITION AND ECONOMIC SAFETY.
WHILE ADDRESS KEY SOCIAL
DETERMINANTS OF HEALTH WHILE
ENSURING ALL CALIFORNIANS
REGARDLESS OF IMMIGRATION
STATUS CAN LIVE FULL AND
HEALTHY LIVES. AND FOURTH
EXPAND EMPLOYMENT OPPORTUNITIES
CREATE CONCRETE EMPLOYMENT
PATHWAYS FOR PROMOTE THOUGHT S.
ROLES THAT PROVIDE FAIR WAGES
AND CAREER DEVELOPMENT
OPPORTUNITIES. IN ADDITION
RIVAS IN EXISTING PROMOTE
THOUGHT AT AND CONTACT TRACING
POSITION QUALIFICATIONS TO MAKE
LANGUAGE IMMIGRATION STATUS AND
EDUCATION REQUIREMENTS MORE
FLEXIBLE OR EVEN OPTIONAL. THIS
WILL ENSURE THAT KEY COMMUNITY
MEMBERS HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
BE HIRED AND GROW THEIR
FINANCIAL STABILITY ALL WHILE
EFFECTIVELY TAPPING INTO TRUST
AND COMMUNICATION NETWORKS
WHICH WILL MAKE THE OUTRAGE
WORK TRULY SUCCESSFUL. IN ORDER
TO ACHIEVE TRUE EQUITY WE MUST
PURSUE A CULTURE OF HEALTH. THE
THEORY OF HUMAN CAPITAL TELL
SAYS THAT IN ORDER FOR THE
ECONOMY TO BEHEALTHY WE NEED
TO ENSURE THAT OUR COMMUNITIES
AND MORE SPECIFICALLY THE
PEOPLE THAT CONTRIBUTE TO THAT
ECONOMY ARE ALSO HEALTHY. AS WE
HEARD EARLIER TODAY LATINOS ARE
A POWERFUL ECONOMIC FORCE AND
WHEN WE CHIU SUPER THICK
LATINAS. WE SUCCESSFULLY CREATE
A RIPPLE EFFECT THAT INSURANCE
PROTECTS FOOL NETWORKS ACROSS
THE STATE. MY INTENTIONALLY
IMPROVING THE HEALTH OF THOSE
MOST DISPROPORTIONATELY
AFFECTED WE IMPROVE THE LIVES
OF ALL CALIFORNIANS. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SIR GREAT PALACE DO
WE HAVE QUESTIONS FROM IF NOT
WE'RE GONNA GO TO OF MISCREANTS
YOU HAD A QUESTION. SILICON
GRAPHICS AND THEN IN ESPANOL A
LESSON ON A AND THEN THIS COULD
LOOK AT THEM YES THEN EMAIL- IS
UNIMPORTANT THE POOR LITTLE YOU
LESS. LESS EVEN INTERVALS
OTHERWISE THE LIST OF THOSE
PERCENT MEDIC ONE NOT THE NAY
MOST OF THE FINANCES ANY ANA.
GET OKAY SET BACK. INCREMENTAL
AT THE I CANNOT SOME GLAD IN
THIS AND WAY YOU ALL I. NICE
THAT I. ALMOST TO THE IT CHAIR
WOMAN MUST SAY. ONE OF THEM
THAT COMMITTEE WHAT. LEARN
WOMEN GO- BLAME PUT TO THIS TO
COME THAT EAT THEM PUT THEM TO
POOL THEY DON'T NEED THE TO
COME IN THAT THE LAST THEY QUE
STANDING THAT THE- A I WAS THE
ENCODE THIS UNITED EIGHT MORE
TIME OKAY STUDY TO I DON'T KNOW
AND THEN SOME NICE BLACK
BECAUSE GAME ANYONE ELSE ON THE
COME WITH THE MOST. THAT IT
LOOKS SO FOR SOME MUST AND ARAB
THIS PERSON THAT ONE WHY-
DIFFIDENCE AND TECHNO I THE FIT
INTO AND MEDIA MAMA HE DONE. AT
MUCHAS COSAS A **** IN INTIMATE
AFFORDABLE THAT ARE THAT ARE
THIS LIST ESSENTIAL CORE ALSO A.
AND REGIONAL COORDINATOR FOR
HER TESTIMONY IN SPANISH THIS
IS THE PEOPLE'S HOUSE AND
SOMETIMES WE HAVE A LOT OF
CHALLENGES WHEN IT COMES TO
LANGUAGE BARRIERS CULTURAL
BARRIERS BUT AT THE END OF THE
DAY IT IS UP TO US AND WE ARE
CHARGED WITH THE OPPORTUNITY TO
OFFER SPACE IN EQUITY- TO
EVERYONE THE CALL CALIFORNIA
HOME AND MANY OF THE MANY OF
THE CHALLENGES THAT SHE SPOKE
ABOUT IN TERMS OF. ESSENTIAL
WORKERS- MENTAL HEALTH
CHALLENGES WITH- COVE IN
NINETEEN LACK OF RESOURCES THE
ABILITY TO PAY YOUR RENT AND
HAVE FOOD ON THE TABLE ARE ALL
THE ITEMS THAT MANY OF US. HAVE
BEEN TALKING ABOUT WHEN IT
COMES TO EQUITY TO RESOURCES
AND I WANNA THANK OUR OUR
CHAIRWOMAN GONZALEZ FOR THE
IMPORTANCE OF THE SELECT
COMMITTEE AND ALLOWING AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR VOICES THAT ARE
OFTEN NOT HEARD TO BE HEARD
INSIDE THE PEOPLE'S HOUSE. SO
THANK YOU. THANK YOU IS THERE
ANY ADDITIONAL COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS. MR OKAY WITH THAT I
THANK YOU- WE ARE GOING TO-
MOVE ON IS THERE ANY PUBLIC
COMMENT. NO. FOR NO MEMBERS IN
THE ROOM THAT I'M SURE
APOLOGIZE NO RIGHT I THINK ON
THE PHONE IS THAT THE OPTIONS
DO WE HAVE SOME PUBLIC COMMENT
ON THE PHONE OKAY WILL MOVE TO
THAT. FOR THOSE OF YOU ON THE
PHONE THAT WOULD LIKE TO MAKE A
PUBLIC COMMENT AT THIS TIME ME
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO.
USING YOUR TELEPHONE. AGAIN
THOSE INSTRUCTIONS ARE ONE. AND
THEN ZERO. BE JUST A MOMENT FOR
A FIRST COMMENT. G. MOBILE-
MOBILE THE. WHILE WE WAIT MADAM
CHAIRWOMAN I'M TOLD BY MY TEAM
THAT IT'S PRESIDENT OF THE
COMIC THEY LOVE BEING IN THE
SPANISH TRANSLATION FOR
CHAIRWOMAN. MAKES SENSE. I DO
HAVE SEVERAL SPEAKERS AT THE
MICROPHONE SILVA FIRST ONLINE
THIRTEEN ONE THREE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI GOOD AFTERNOON ON A
SEVENTH ST THANK YOU FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO PROVIDE COMMENT
ON SUCH IMPORTANT ISSUES TO ME
BOTH PERSONALLY AND
PROFESSIONALLY I THAT THE AND I
AM WORKERS RETURNING CALIFORNIA
MY NAME IS MONEY AT THAT CAN
AFFECT THE TRAINING AT LEGAL
AID AT WORK A NONPROFIT THAT
PROVIDES FREE LEGAL EDUCATION.
ADVICE AND ADVOCACY FOR LOW
WAGE WORKERS ACROSS THE STATE I
WANT TO SPEAK TO THE IMPORTANCE
OF PAID SICK DAYS AND- THE
PARTICIPATION OF THIS ISSUE AS
A VITAL LIFELINE FOR ALL
WORKERS IN PARTICULAR THAT YOU
KNOW WHO ARE SUFFERING A
DISPROPORTIONATE AND ALARMING
RATE. AS WE HEARD FROM OUR
MEETING PALACE EARLIER AT LIKE
YOU KNOW WOMEN
DISPROPORTIONATELY WORK IN SOME
OF THE HARDEST HIT SECTORS IN
THE PANDEMIC OFTEN HERBAL THAT
LACK THE ABILITY TO WORK FROM
HOME. SINCE THE BEGINNING OF
THE PANDEMIC WE RECEIVED
THOUSANDS OF CALLS FROM WORKERS
IMPACTED BY COVER NINETEEN WHEN
THEY'VE HAD ACCESS TO PAID SICK
DAYS THERE WILL TO STAY HOME
AND STOP THE SPREAD BUT WHEN
THEY HAVE IT IT WAS FORCED INTO
AN IMPOSSIBLE CHOICE. EITHER GO
TO WORK I READ WRITING COVERED
NINETEENTH BIRTHDAY HOME A
LOOSE AND COME AND THEIR JOB
I'M SURE YOU WOULDN'T BE
SURPRISED TO HEAR THAT THINKING
THAT CHOICE SOME. WORKERS HAVE
CHOSEN TO KEEP WORKING. WE KNOW
THAT EITHER JANUARY OF. THERE
NO BETTER PAID SICK DAYS AND
EXTENSION STATE COUPLE. PICTURE
AND THE- MANTA WERE. IN LATINOS
INTO PROJECT AND- I THE SAME ON
THE COVER GREAT HAVE BEEN SORRY
AN ICE USER. THE HAVE. WITH A
PATH TO. THIS IS DIFFERENT.
STUDIES HAVE. THAT PAPER DATE
HOW STATE BY DURING THE MAC. WE
NEED TO STAY I TWENTY THE
WORKING. WITH PUBLIC HEALTH
DIRECTIVE AND STOP THE SPREAD
OF COPING. TICKETS GET THEIR
INCOME AND- THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY. THANK NEXT GO TO
OF TWELVE ONE TWO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. THANK YOU MY NAME'S ON
MERGING AT THE TIME TO HELP THE
WOMAN IN THE CITY OF MORGAN
HILL. AND WHAT I WANT TO FIRST
THANK. YOU FOR HAVING THIS
COMMITTEE- IF YOU DIDN'T KNOW
THAT IT WAS SO WIDELY NEEDED-
WE WOULDN'T BE HERE TODAY THANK
YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER- AND SHARE
NOT IN A COURT FILING WELL
SENATOR MARTY AND THEN AFTER
THAT BEFORE GOING TO WORK. I'M
THRILLED TO SEE- MY FAMILY
MEMBER RIVAS AS WELL AS A
FAMILY MEMBER ASH KALRA THERE
AS WELL- I GUESS WHAT I'LL SAY
IS. I REALLY AM HOPING AND
URGING THEM AND I KNOW THAT YOU
KNOW THAT THE PART OF IT IS
PREACHING TO THE CHOIR BUT WE
HAVE TO ENSURE THE SPRINT.
THAT'S THE AND THAT WE HAVE
SOME PROTECTIONS FOR OUR OUR
COMMUNITY HERE WHEN THEY HIT.
THE FIRST THING THAT CAME AND
ALARMS ME WHAT THE NUMBER. OF
PEOPLE WHO HAD REACHED OUT TO
ME. I WE'RE SHARING. IN STORIES-
AND PURCHASE STORY. YOU CONVEY
IS THE NEED THAT THEY WERE IN-
IT WAS SO MOVING AND JUST
UNDERSTANDING THAT. WHEN THEY
WERE TALKING TO ME SAYING LOOK
I'VE I'VE LOST MY JOB SOMEBODY
SAID. AND I CAN'T FIND WHO I
CAN FIND. YOU KNOW SOME OF
THESE OTHER SHORT TERM NEEDS.
BUT I AM NOT ABLE TO FIND
SOMEBODY WHO CAN HELP ME COVER
MY RENT. I THINK THAT THAT'S
SOMETHING CRITICAL THAT- WHEN
WE HAVE SO MANY SINGLE. WOMEN
LATINOS OFTEN WHO ARE HEAD OF
HOUSEHOLD THAT ARE FACING THIS
ALONE- WE NEED TO STEP IN AND
MAKE SURE THAT WE THAT WE THINK
THAT THERE. ARE ALSO I THINK IN
ORDER TO REALLY LOOK AT HOW MY
PEERS ARE BEING. IMPACTED IT
OUT THERE. NOT ONLY ARE WE
WORKING NOT ONLY ARE WE HEAD OF
HOUSEHOLD. BUT BAKHTIN YELLING
AND JUGGLING CHILD CARE AS WELL
AND AS WE KNOW OUR LIBRARIES
HAVE BEEN SHOT OUR SCHOOLS HAVE
BEEN SHUT. OUR AFTER SCHOOL
PROGRAMS HAVE BEEN SHOT DURING
KOBE. AND SO WE NEED TO ENSURE
THAT THERE ARE SOME TYPE OF
SUPPORT. SAYING WE HAVE O
SHELTER AT HOME AND SOMEHOW
FIGURE IT OUT IS JUST NOT. IT'S
JUST NOT WORKING FOR PEOPLE AND
SO. AS WE MOVE FORWARD WE'VE
HAD PEOPLE STEP UP WITH THE
CENTRAL CARE- FOR. THAT AT
CHILD CARE FOR CENTRAL WORKERS
WHICH IS FANTASTIC AND I WOULD
REALLY LOVE TO. EMPHASIZE THAT
WE COULD HAVE MORE SUPPORT ON
THAT YOU'RE NOT GOING TO BE
ABLE TO FREE. OUR LATINA. UNTIL
WE'RE ABLE TO- ADDRESS THEIR
FIRST IMPORTANT FORM. FIRST AND
FOREMOST THE ISSUES THAT THEY
HAVE AT HAND WHICH IS CHILD
CARE AND TAKING CARE OF THE
HOME- AND THEN FINALLY JUST. TO
US SAYING THAT I WOULD
ABSOLUTELY THE SECOND AN ECHO
ALL OF THE COMMENTS MADE
AROUND. WOMEN WHO ARE LEADING
US TO INFORM WORKING FOOD
PACKING THE HAIR SALONS WHICH
IS PREDOMINANTLY YOU KNOW AND
NOT JUST ONLINE BUT ALSO
SERVICING. WHICH IS ALL
PREDOMINANTLY LED BY WOMEN AND
WE KNOW THAT YOU KNOW HER DATE
THE POPULATION AT THAT THANK
YOU FOR YOUR WORK TODAY AND I
CONTINUE TO SUPPORT YOU IN
EVERY. WAY THAT. I CAN FROM MY
SMALL TOWN. THANK YOU AND IT
BECAUSE IT'S PRIME BEEN BROUGHT
A FEW TO I WANT. TO NO WE DID A
FACT PASS AS TEN IT REALLY TO
DO. AND LANDLORD RELATE THAT WE
HOPE WILL- START THE PROCESS OF
ALLEVIATING SOME OF THAT STRESS
AND KEEP PEOPLE IN THEIR HOUSE
AT THE HOUSE ENOUGH AT LEAST-
THREE JONAH US SO IT'S
SOMETHING WE'LL CONTINUE TO
WORK ON BUT I KNOW THAT'S BEEN
BROUGHT UP A FEW TIMES AND IT
IS SOMETHING THAT. WE
ANTICIPATE WILL GET SIGNED BY
THE GOVERNOR AND WE WILL HAVE
IN PLACE BEFORE FEBRUARY FIRST.
I'M WEARING CNTINUE WITH
PUBLIC COMMENT I SHOULD HAVE
SAID THIS TO START WITH IF WE
CAN KEEP OUR COMMENTS TO ONE
MINUTE- LET YOU GO A LITTLE BIT
OVER BUT BUT- WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE WE CATCH OUR FLIGHTS SO.
IS THERE ADDITIONAL PUBLIC
COMMENT. FIRST ARE FEW MORE IN
Q. NEXT DEADLINE FOURTEEN ONE
FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THIS IS
KATIE WATER SMITH BUT THAT
CALIFORNIA WORK AND FAMILY
COALITION WE VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE THE IMPORTANT
QUESTION TODAY ON THE IMPACT OF
COVERT NINETEEN ON THE LATINO
COMMUNITY- WOULD LIKE TO ALIGN
OUR COMMENTS BUT BOTH OF LEGAL
AID AT WORK AS WE ARE ALSO
CALLING ON THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATURE TO ADOPT EMERGENCY
TYPICALLY PROVISIONS IN ANY
IMMEDIATE BUDGET THAT MONTHS.
THANK YOU. THANK YOUNG. NEXT WE
HAVE A COMMENT FROM LINE
SIXTEEN ONE SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
MY NAME IS VANESSA GONZALEZ-
STRATEGIES AND I REPRESENT
CALIFORNIA LATINAS FOR
REPRODUCTIVE JUSTICE A
STATEWIDE POLICY ADVOCACY
ORGANIZATION. I THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR THIS IMPORTANT
DISCUSSION AS YOU DISCUSSED
TAKEOVER IN NINETEEN HAS LAID
BARE THE RACIAL AND INCOME
BASED HEALTH INEQUITIES LARGELY
ROOTED IN THE STATE'S LEGACY OF
EUGENICS. WANTED TO EXAMPLE OF
THE DEPLORABLE PRACTICE THAT
TOOK PLACE IN CALIFORNIA OVER
SEVERAL DECADES WHERE WOMEN IN
STATE INSTITUTIONS WERE
FORCIBLY STERILIZED AND H.
DISPROPORTIONATE AMOUNT WHERE
THAT DENIES WOMEN OF COLOR. IN
pTHAT BETWEEN TWO THOUSAND SIX
IN TWENTY TEN AT LEAST A
HUNDRED AND FORTY FOUR WOMEN
WERE ILLEGALLY STERILISED IN
STATE PRISONS AND 65% OF
SEARCH. SURVIVORS DESCRIBED
THEMSELVES AS BLACK HISPANIC.
MEXICAN OR OTHER. AND ALTHOUGH
ONLY RECENTLY HAS THE CAR BEEN
ON LOS THIS HAS YET TO FOLLOW
WITH ANY JUSTICE FOR THE
SURVIVORS. AIRPORT KELLY
CALIFORNIA LATINAS FOR
REPRODUCTIVE JUSTICE ALONG WITH
DOZENS OF WOMEN'S. WOMEN'S AND
VICTIM'S RIGHTS ORGANIZATIONS
HAVE COLLECTED THE FORTY SEVEN
POINT FIVE MILLION DOLLAR
BUDGET REQUESTS FROM ASSEMBLY.
WOMAN WENDY CARILLO THAT WOULD
PROVIDE FUNDING TO ESTABLISH A
RESTITUTION FUND FOR THE
SURVIVORS. I KNOW SOMEBODY
WOMAN GONZALEZ AND OTHER
MEMBERS OF THE WOMEN'S AND LET
YOU KNOW CAUCUSES HAVE
EXPRESSED THEIR SUPPORT. AND WE
HOPE TO BE SUCCESSFUL THIS YEAR
IN BRINGING SOME NOT MODIFIABLE
OBJECTION THANK YOU. THANK YOU
IN ONE NOTED THAT MIGHT BE A
GOOD TOPIC FOR A FUTURE HEARING
AS WELL JUST LETTING IS
REPRODUCTIVE JUSTICE IN
GENERAL. WE'LL GO TO THE NEXT
COLOR. NEXT CALLER LINE
SEVENTEEN IF OTHERS WOULD LIKE
TO MAKE COMMENTS IN THE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO LINE SEVENTEEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON KAREN MEMBERS MY NAME
IS JACKIE GRAY WATER
LEGISLATIVE ADVOCATE WITH YOUR
P. W. ACTING STATE COUNCIL
SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF A HUNDRED
AND EIGHTY THOUSAND FRONT LINEUP W. MEMBERS IN CALIFORNIA. I
KNOW THAT WE ARE SHORT ON TIME
TODAY WITH MEMBERS THAT NEED TO
CATCH FLIGHT BUT I WILL- ECHO
THE COMMENTS THAT LEGAL AID AT
WORK IN THE WORKING FAMILY
COALITION HAVE MADE. AND THEN
JUST ONE APPOINTED TO STUDIES
THAT SHOW FOR THE- DIRE NEED
FOR EMERGENCY PAID SICK LEAVE
THERE WITH EVERYTHING REQUIRED
BY THE L. A. L. THAT LET YOU
KNOW WORKERS ARE MORE LIKELY TO
WORK IN FRONT LINE INDUSTRIES
ARE EXPOSURE TO COVER NINETEEN
IS GREATER. I'M IN THAT LETS
YOU KNOW WORKERS ACTUALLY MAKE
UP HALF OF THE STATE'S FRONT
LINE I WORKFORCE MANY OF THEM
WHO ARE YOU SEE W. MEMBERS. I'M
IN AND THERE'S A RECENT STUDY
FROM THE ECONOMIC POLICY
INSTITUTE THAT SHOW THAT LATINO
WORKERS ARE LESS LIKELY THAN
WHITE WORKERS. BE ABLE TO TAKE
PAID SICK LEAVE TWO THIRDS OF
WHITE WORKERS HOBBY ABILITY TO
EARN PAID SICK DAYS COMPARED TO
ONLY 44406% OF LATINO WORKERS.
I THANK YOU FOR THE TIME. TODAY
AND BRED OFTEN HEARING. THE
YOU. ARE THERE. COLORS BROUGH
OVERALL FIFTY ONE FIVE YOUR
LINE IS. HELLO AND THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR ALL OF THE WONDERFUL
INFORMATION AND REPRESENTATION
TODAY MY NAME IS KARISHMA KEY-
I UNDERSTAND COUNTY
BREASTFEEDING COALITION DOWN
SOUTH HERE IN SAN DIEGO. AND I
JUST WANT TO SHARE A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT- A PERSONAL STORY AND THE
FEDERAL EMERGENCY PAID SICK
DAYS ARE SO IMPORTANT TO. THE
HEALTH CARE OF OUR HEALTH CARE
SYSTEM AND ALSO- LATINOS- MY
BEST FRIEND IS A LATINO WORKER-
SHE WORKED IN FOOD SERVICE AND
SHE IS AN EXACT EXAMPLE OF THIS
EXPLORATION SHE DID CONTRACT CO
THE NINETEEN. SHE HAD
ABSOLUTELY NO CHOICE BUT TO GO
TO WORK WHEN INFECTIOUS IT WAS
EITHER THAT OR LOSE THE RECOVER
HAD AND SHE HAS A YOUNG SON SO.
HAVE YOU ALL MADE KNOWN
UNDERSTAND THAT'S THE DECISION
YOU NEVER REALLY WANT TO COME
ACROSS SO UNFORTUNATELY. AT THE
TIME WHERE WE'RE SEEING
MILLIONS OF YOU KNOW INFECTION
RATES ARE RISING- THIS WAS
SOMETHING THAT I JUST. HAD TO
SPEAK OUT ABOUT- PAID SICK DAYS
SAVE LIVES AND THEY'RE REALLY
ESSENTIAL TO. ALSO SLOWING
BECOMING NINETEEN TRANSMISSION
SO WE JUST NEED TO FOCUS ON THE
EXPANDING EMERGENCY PAID SICK
DAYS- AND I JUST WANTED TO
THANK- ASSEMBLYMEMBERS OUTS ALL
AS IN THE ENTIRE. COMMITTEE FOR
THEIR WORK ON THIS THANK YOU SO
MUCH. THANK YOU. HEATHER DO
COLORS. NO FURTHER QUESTIONS IN
QUEUE. THANK YOU AND- THAT IS
THE LAST OF OUR COMMITTEE
HEARING I DO WANT TO KNOW
BECAUSE THERE WAS A LOT OF
ATTENTION PAID TO EMERGENCY
PAID SICK DAYS AND OF COURSE- I
THINK SOME OF THE COLORS OF
THIS BUT I IT OUR OFFICE AND I
AM SURE SOME OF MY COLLEAGUES
WILL BE ASKING FOR THAT
EXTENSION AND THE BUDGET-
PROCESS THIS YEAR SO THAT IS
SOMETHING THAT WE WILL CONTINUE
TO WORK ON- ALL THE ISSUES
BROUGHT UP OR THINGS I THINK
WE'VE BEEN WORKING ON AND I'VE
SEEN. THE NEED FORCE I WANT TO
THANK EVERYBODY WHO
PARTICIPATED THE PANELISTS-
ABSOLUTELY AMAZING LEVINE AS
WHO WHO TOLD THEIR STORIES AND
WHO TOLD ABOUT THAT THE FAX OF
WHAT'S GOING ON- THE
PARTICIPANTS IN OUR COMMITTEE
AND TO OF COURSE EVEN THOSE WHO
CALLED IN AND- EXPRESS THEIR
OPINIONS AS WELL WITH THAT THAT
IS OUR INAUGURAL- LATINOS. IN
EQUITIES SELECT COMMITTEE I
ALMOST CALLED WOMEN THE
WORKPLACE THAT'S WHAT I HAD
BEFORE. FORGET A LITTLE BIT
MORE SPECIFIC EVERY TIME. AND
LOOK FORWARD TO OUR NEXT
HEARING WHICH WE ANTICIPATE-
WILL BE. DEALING WITH THE
UNSEEN LEVINE AS AND IN THE
PUBLIC SPHERE ESPECIALLY IN
HOLLYWOOD WITH THAT. OUR
MEETING OF OUR.